arrimé des pays africains à l'euro c'est
une évidence bêtise la france a intérêt
à maintenir de francs cfa parce que
c'est long mais c'est leur instrument
qu'ils ont la protection de ses intérêts
économiques en afrique
l'écho c'est quelque chose qui était
fait entre pays africains et sur lequel
la france et l'europe avait pas grand
chose à dire en question de la date avec
fixe avait dit non mais c'est est ce que
c'est la même monnaie et avoir la même
prochain le sujet aujourd'hui en afrique
c'est pas d'avoir une inflation à 2%
ces espèces de critères qu'on impose
alors c'est des critères de qui a entre
guillemets d'économies matures à des
économies qui sont en développement
studio
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur arte france
pour deux heures d'émission nous
décrypterons comme chaque soir du lundi
au jeudi l'essentiel de l'information
avec nos invités en plateau et nos
reporters sur le terrain voici les
grands pics de l'actualité de ce jeudi
23 janvier
[Musique]
le 5e forum international sur la shoah
s'est tenue aujourd'hui à jérusalem de
nombreux dirigeants présents dont
vladimir poutine emmanuel macron ou
encore mike pence
une journée pour se souvenir également
des soldats de l'armée rouge libérateur
du camp d'auschwitz ce matin le
président russe a assisté à
l'inauguration d'un monument consacré à
ceux qui ont subi le siège de leningrad
la très attendue conférence sur le
financement des retraites proposée par
la cfdt elle débutera finalement le 30
janvier prochain et voir philippe vient
de le confirmer au confrère de la croix
la feuille de route fixée par le
gouvernement aux partenaires sociaux et
street à trouver d'ici avril un moyen
d'équilibrer les comptes sens du coût du
travail ni baisse des pensions
faute de quoi matignon ressortir à son
âge pivot à 64 ans alors quelles sont
les chances de réussite de cette
conférence est il vraiment nécessaire
d'équilibrer les retraites autant de
questions auxquelles répondra jacques
sapir dans son édito échos ce soir
les discussions commerciales entre les
états unis et l'europe sont un signal
positif déclarations de christine
lagarde présidente de la bce et même
écran et donald trump prolonge les
discussions sur la taxation des géants
du numérique jusqu'à la fin de l'année
l'ombre de la menace de sanctions
américaines et deux sur taxes sur des
produits français s'éloigne pour
l'instant
[Musique]
j'en ai mémorielle donc aujourd'hui
notamment pour se souvenir de la
libération du camp d'auschwitz c'était
le 27 janvier il y a tout juste 75 ans
les dirigeants du monde entier sont à
jérusalem pour participer au forum
mondial de la shoah israël où se trouve
notre envoyé spécial tome abonnés
pendant plus de trois heures les
discours se sont succédé des discours
parfois plein d'émotions toujours très
grave qui rendent souvent hommage aux
victimes de la shoah et également aux
survivants de l'holocauste qui pour
certains d'entre eux sont présents au
mémorial de yad vashem c'est le
président israélien rivlin qui a appris
la parole en premier avec ces mots très
forts les portes de l'enfer se sont
ouvertes le 27 janvier 1945 le 27
janvier 1945 c'est la date à laquelle
l'armée rouge a libéré le camp
d'auschwitz on retiendra également les
propos de vladimir poutine qui a
expliqué que l'union soviétique a payé
un lourd tribut avec environ 27 millions
de morts pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale beaucoup de juifs étaient
originaires d'union soviétique a déclaré
vladimir poutine qui a également pointé
la collaboration de certains pays avec
l'allemagne nazie il faut défendre la
vérité et la justice a par ailleurs
déclaré le président russe vladimir
poutine qui a également soumis une idée
est celle de la tenue d'une réunion du
conseil de sécurité des nations unies en
2020 est ce la lumière de la coopération
efficace des pays alliés en 1945
une réunion du conseil de sécurité des
nations unies cette année une idée
approuvée par emmanuel macron nous
écoutent les cinq grandes puissances
fondatrice de l'onu sont garantes du
maintien de la civilisation nous en
avons des parler avec mes homologues et
nous sommes tout à fait d'accord sur
d'organiser une réunion des deux cp
c'est à dire états unis
russie chine france et grande bretagne
pour que nous puissions parler de cela
n'importe où n'importe où et la russie
tout à fait prête à accueillir un tel
forum intel d'une telle discussion et je
vous rejoins cher vladimir monsieur le
président poutine les cinq membres
permanents du conseil de sécurité des
nations unies ont aujourd'hui une
responsabilité historique
je partage votre volonté 75 ans plus
tard de nous rassembler tous ensemble
nous l'avons évoqué il ya quelques jours
et je souhaite que nous puissions le
faire car nous sommes de par cette
histoire est depuis la fin du deuxième
conflit mondial les garants d'un ordre
international qui tient par le droit la
légalité et le respect de chacun au delà
des hommages les discours étaient
parfois très politique ce fut notamment
le cas lorsque benyamin netanyahou le
premier ministre israélien a pris la
parole au pupitre il a d'abord insisté
sur l'importance de l'armée israélienne
et de ce qu'il qualifie de boucliers un
bouclier contre les menaces et il a
nommé très directement une de ces
menaces
selon lui il s'agit de l'iran un
discours repris par les etats-unis
représentés cet après midi par le
vice-président américain mike pence on
écoute nous devons encore attendre une
action résolue g contre le régime le
plus antisémite ce qui existe sur la
planète
un régime qui cherche ouvertement à
développer des armes nucléaires pour
anéantir l'unique le seul état juif ce
plan ces tyrans de téhéran qui ont
merci quitter leur propre peuple et qui
met en cause la sécurité de toute la
région de tous les pays du proche orient
et même du monde entier j'appelle tous
les jours vers demandent à rejoindre cet
effort est essentielle et à faire face à
l'iran il ne s'inspire dans ce même
esprit oui mais nous devons aussi rester
fort contre cet état prévalant
d'antisémitisme contre un gouvernement
montrent qui adopte une étape nier la
shoah et qu'ils voudraient c'est israël
de la carte mondiale est bien le coup et
d'israël doit rester fermes contre la
république islamique d'iran
une cérémonie qui s'est terminée par des
hommages successifs des différentes
délégations internationales présentes
elles sont au nombre de 49 49
personnalités politiques des 49 pays qui
ont fait le déplacement ici à jérusalem
pour ce qui est qualifié de plus grand
événement diplomatique de l'histoire du
pays et pour en parler nous sommes en
direct depuis jérusalem avec kalinda
grafstein correspondante de voice of
america en israël c'est notre rubrique
vu de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir linda gray sting merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france
qu'est-ce que vous retiendrez vous de
cette journée de mémoire de ce forum de
la shoah aujourd'hui c'était une journée
très émotionnel je pense que touchant
c'était la présence du président
allemand monsieur steinmeier qui a
déclaré qui a téléchargé par la
culpabilité des actes des nazis contre
les juges ont lancé une bénédiction et
break
l'idée que le président à lyon se
sentent 15 ans que la libération de
suite soit à jérusalem est par et pour
eux
et bien c'est très touchant pour
beaucoup de personnes ça vous semble
indispensable ces forums c'est devoir de
mémoire à chaque anniversaire c'est
important pour ne pas répéter l'histoire
je pense effectivement que c'est
important de marquer l'anniversaire
important le 25.5 en tiens on attendait
73e importante également survivants de
l'holocauste se porte très bien de ce
qui s'est passé et y est ils sont quand
même
et d'ici quelques années il n'y en aura
plus aujourd'hui il y en a encore tout
ce sont 15 minutes ici à quelques arrêts
il ne restera presque plus je pense que
c'est important de se souvenir car nous
le voyons dans le monde entier il ya de
plus en plus de voix qu'ils disent que
le low cost n'a jamais eu lieu que
c'était une invention que c'est un
complot juif avec ces célébrations
mémorielle on me permets de rappeler et
n'ont donc cela a eu
et avec un peu de chance toute forme de
génocide de quelque peuple que ce soit
n'aura pas lieu une étude ifop 1 qui
date de 2008 en france indique que chez
nous en tout cas un français sur dix
ignorer l'existence de la shoah ça
paraît incroyable
est ce que ça vous semble crédible ce
type d'étude et et est ce que c'est
quelque chose qui a lieu également dans
d'autres pays
il faut sans m'inquiéter parce que c'est
effectivement un sujet de préoccupation
et aux etats unis également je pense
qu'encore plus de personnes ont jamais
entendu parler de la shoah ou ne pense
pas que six millions de juifs ont été
tués parce que tout ça a été inventé de
toutes pièces
il est très difficile histoire ce qu'on
connaît l'histoire que cela soit
possible
mais les gens ce qu'ils veulent croire
ce genre de forum légal avec 49 chefs
d'état et des hauts représentants permet
d'attirer l'attention sur cela avec
autant de chefs d'état réunis à un
endroit alors forcément l'attention va
être tourné sur cet endroit
chose qui est vraie et les historiens de
le parquetier ce qui devrait avoir plus
d'éducation fernand comme informelle
autour de la shoah des douzaines dimane
de ce règlement notamment en arabie
saoudite seront visitées le commando
suite justement c'était ma question pour
vous il ne s'agit pas que de la
responsabilité des gouvernements pour
introduire évidemment ces programmes
dans les livres d'histoire c'est déjà
finalement le cas mais c'est le devoir
de finalement tout citoyen et
et de tout responsable de quelques
religions que ce soit de ce devoir de
mémoire notamment sur la choisissent
pour les autres génocides évidemment des
autres peuples
en israël beaucoup de lys on se rende à
auschwitz enfin voir de leurs propres
yeux les camps de concentration vers la
fin de leur cursus plusieurs mois à
étudier le low cost que je pense qu'il
est très important que tombé sur un
quartier il faut qu'on ait une fois
qu'on voit de ses propres yeux
cela rappelle et cela rend impossible
d'imaginer l'ampleur de cette terreur il
ya également des musées sur les postes
dans le monde entier se trouve le
mémorial et un musée extraordinaire avec
des centaines et des centaines
d'artefacts de films de photographies
c'est une autre façon je vais maintenir
la barre et d'essayer de comprendre je
pense que toutes les nations
est ce que ma vie où je mets du nord
s'engage à et dire qu'elle n'en diront
pas et c'est le cas que faire en
pratique comment étudier le génocide des
juifs ne devrait pas permettre le
génocide de quelque peuple que ce soit
ce gant et élus locaux souvent plus
jamais ça et beaucoup de dirigeants
d'aujourd'hui mais monsieur netanyahou
le aziz président américain mc pense la
presse dans ma quand ils ont tous dit
plus jamais ça
je pense que les millions de doit se
rappeler cela sinon on ne se bat pas
contre le mal
alors il peut gagner et causé la mort de
coups d'innocents vous vous êtes cité
bayemi netanyahu qui a aussi fait un
petit peu de politiques en critiquant
durement lire
le régime tyrannique est-ce que selon
vous c'était le moment opportun pour ce
message là à ce que la question
intéressante
certaines personnes disent qu'ils n'en
étaient pas d'user des politiques
aujourd'hui je pense que le premier
ministre voit ce qui se passe en iran et
les efforts iraniens pour acquérir la
bombe nucléaire comme le résultat direct
de l'holocauste livrons en tant que
régime dont le low cost
je pense que pour lui c'est une menace
existentielle envers israël et c'est
pour cela qu'il a ses permis d'être
boules sic dans son discours certes il
ya eu des critiques et certaines
personnes nanties il a déjà dit cela
plusieurs reprises et peut-être
qu'aujourd'hui n'aurait pas dû merci
beaucoup en tout cas linda gray de nous
avoir apporté votre analyse après cette
journée la réunion tous ses dirigeants à
jérusalem pour le forum de la shoah
merci beaucoup à vous plusieurs chefs de
d'état d'état sont arrivés dès hier
jérusalem notamment emmanuel macron une
journée marquée par cette altercation du
président français largement relayé par
les réseaux sociaux on y voit emmanuel
macron haussé le ton avec un policier
israélien une scène filmée qui rappelle
évidemment celle vécue il ya 24 ans par
jacques chirac alors que le président
français est attendu à la basilique
sainte anne à jérusalem domaine français
dans la vieille ville il a exigé que les
policiers israéliens le laisse passer
il s'en est expliqué un petit peu plus
tard ils vont à sainte anne qui est un
domaine français
et l'injure qui était assez classique il
ya eu un moment de d'énervement entre
des équipes de sécurité et il me
revenait il mettre bon ordre a expliqué
quelles sont les règles
depuis que la france a ainsi quelques
domaines et c'est vrai pour sainte-anne
la sécurité israélienne qui a fait un
travail formidable mais côté dans les
rues
tout a été très calme elle s'arrête aux
portes de sainte-anne essai de sécurité
françaises qui prend le relais et c'est
pour cela qu'hier je n'aurais pas dit
c'était prémédité
non pas du tout parce que je pensais que
ça se passerait bien mais c'est vous qui
le faites mais non non non non c'était
pas les pas de préméditation est ce que
je pensais que ça se passerait bien
c'est un peu le jeu la parenthèse a été
a été refermé et plusieurs personnalités
politiques ont immédiatement réagi sur
les réseaux sociaux avec une certaine
ironie parfois regarder singer chirac
pour faire oublier qu'il mène la
politique de sarkozy l'imitation de
jacques chirac est plein de bonne
volonté accent français inclus mais cela
sonne moins spontané mâcon va même
jusqu'à exagéré son accent français en
anglais pourtant meilleur d'habitude
pour singer chirac absolument ridicule
si macron veut imiter chirac qu'il
retire son projet de réforme contre nos
retraites
comme chirac avait retiré son contrat
première embauche face à la mobilisation
populaire et pour décrypter l'actualité
nous sommes avec sergio coronado
écologiste tête de liste à l'élection
municipale a bondi avec le soutien de la
france info me c'est notre invité
politique ce soir
bonsoir bonsoir sergio coronado merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france avant de décrypter l'actualité
notamment françaises
évidemment tu alité sociale chargée on
en parlera cette visite hier on l'a vu
des manuels mais kron dans la vieille
ville de jérusalem et son altercation ou
aussi vous dénoncez à un coup de com
j'avais fait également un tweet qui
mettait en exergue en fait la similitude
avec ce qui s'était passé il ya
plusieurs années
al'approche de la basilique sainte anne
à jérusalem qui est un territoire
français là en l'occurrence
puisque on avait l'impression
effectivement que presque mot-à-mot le
président macron voulait emprunter les
pas de jacques chirac
la différence est que jacques chirac
avait une politique qui lui permettait
en fait d'apparaître comme quelqu'un qui
se faisait respecter notamment par les
services de sécurité israéliens à
l'époque ce qui n'est loin de là
le cas du prison macron dont on voit de
plus en plus
l'atlantisme le suivisme à l'égard de la
politique nord-américaine et donc je
crois en effet que c'est un coup de com
ça a été relevé par plusieurs
observateurs et pas les plus hostiles au
président de la république
voilà qui résume bien en fait la
politique internationale d' emmanuel
macron alors justement sur l'anti
sémitisme 1 et c'est beaucoup et exprimé
également cet anniversaire a été
l'occasion d'évoquer l'augmentation des
actes antisémites en france comment vous
avez perçu le discours du président de
la république qui ont ce n'est pas
nouveau mais il ya une loi qui sur ce
point associés l'antisionisme à
l'antisémitisme et il n'est pas une loi
en fait il s'agit d'une résolution qui
n'est pas contraignant qui n'a pas
atteint en valeur ni les chaînes et
juridique
je crois qu'il ya une très grande
confusion d'ailleurs il y avait eu un
appel l'intellectuel juif et notamment
de grands chercheurs professeurs
écrivains israéliens qui dénonçait la
confusion qu'il y aurait à présenter en
fait toute critique de la politique
gouvernementale israélienne comme une
forme d'antisémitisme
je crois que l'antisémitisme est un
fléau qu'il faut le combattre que nous
disposons en france notamment d'un
arsenal juridique suffisamment complet
et qu'il ne me paraît pas sage il ne me
paraît pas souhaitable de faire d'un
débat politique c'est à dire de
l'appréciation de la politique
israélienne
un combat ou contre l'antisémitisme ou
utiliser cette critique là comme si
c'était en fait une expression de
l'antisémitisme je crois que ce sont
deux choses distinctes
et quand on joue la confusion on
affaiblit en fait la lutte nécessaire
indispensable contre l'antisémitisme
justement vous l'avez vu ces
augmentations d'actes antisémites
comment vous l'expliquez vous et si vous
étiez au pouvoir comment voulu te riez
contre ce fléau en france d'abord on est
un dispositif législatif et juridique
qui permet en fait de poursuivre de
condamner il y a également fait un
travail pédagogique nécessaire et je
crois qu'il y à la fois à une
augmentation des actes antisémites mais
on l'a noté également dans l'actualité
l'augmentation des actes racistes en
général les violences à l'égard des
minorités des personnes lgbt
je crois que cela fait partie d'une des
grandes missions de l'éducation
nationale de construire en fait la
conscience la citoyenneté de lutter
contre les discriminations et le racisme
et ensuite évidemment une attention
particulière moi je le vis comme
candidat aujourd'hui à l'élection miss
elle a bondi contre ces formes de
dérapage ses formes de violence qui
enfreignent en fait la capacité que nous
avons à vivre ensemble à vivre en commun
la loi via par exemple efficace pour
vous est ce qu'elle peut contribuer à
limiter les propos haineux sur internet
et prendre le problème du bon goût quand
je m'attarde sur le texte proposé par
les parlementaires dont madame attias
avocate par ailleurs il fera porter je
me dis que l'enfer est pavé de bonnes
intentions
encore une fois la plupart des
spécialistes les meilleurs connaisseurs
du domaine en fait du numérique
sont vent debout contre ce texte de loi
vous avez vu des dernières déclarations
du syndicat des avocats du conseil
national du numérique de la quadrature
du cercle de la ligue des droits de
l'homme
il y à une évolution inquiétante depuis
des décennies dans notre pays c'est
l'effacement en fait du juge judiciaire
dans ces procédures le juge est le seul
et l'unique garant de nos libertés
le fait de décider de déléguer à des
plateformes privées en fait la capacité
de réguler et donc de censurer mais
paraître un très grand risque
et puis une inquiétude également ses je
ne sais pas ce qui est défini sous le
vocable de haine et c'est très compliqué
d'ailleurs le texte de loi dans son
introduction non-dits pains seulement
d'après une étude qui a été publiée par
le sénat il ya eu 160 mille signalement
sur la plateforme pharos en 2018 et
moins de quatorze mille en fait de ces
signalements pouvaient être rattachées à
des propos de haine ou à des propos de
discrimination donc je crois que
appréhendait la globalité de ce problème
peut paraître une position juste en
revanche les propositions qui sont
aujourd'hui portés par ce texte de loi
vise à généraliser une forme de censure
privé et je crois que c'est très
inquiétant je rappelle par ailleurs
qu'il a été introduit à la demande du
gouvernement un amendement
particulièrement inquiétant sur demande
de la police
il y aurait retrait sous les 24 heures
dans les 24 heures en fait tout une
publication pose en difficulté
qu'en serait-il si cette loi avait été
adopté il ya plusieurs années concernant
par exemple les violences policières qui
ont été d'abord et vous le savez très
bien parce que vous avez été un des
seuls médias a porté la faire devant le
public
constr est il des violences policières
qui ont d'abord été montré sur les
réseaux sociaux qui ont fait l'objet de
signalement et notamment d'un
journaliste bien connu désormais david
dufresne
si la police avait eu cette capacité
finalement à mettre en exergue à
dénoncer à s'opposer à leur diffusion
sous couvert de
propos de haine à l'égard des forces de
l'ordre moi je suis très inquiet en fait
qu'on délègue à des intérêts privés des
plateformes privées la régulation d'un
espace de liberté d'expression et que
par ailleurs la place du juge dans ces
questions qui me paraissent prioritaires
compte à nos libertés soit à chaque fois
marginalisée l'actualité c'est aussi
évidemment toujours le projet de réforme
des retraites avec une nouvelle grande
journée de mobilisation demain alors que
dans le même temps le projet est
présenté en conseil des ministres vous
pensez que ça va encore changer quelque
chose de se mobiliser le gouvernement a
l'air déterminé à aller jusqu'au bout
le gouvernement a l'air évidemment
déterminé depuis le départ d'ailleurs on
a deux ans
2-2 de négociation factice a pour dire
les choses telles qu'elles ont été vécus
par les principaux acteurs et notamment
du monde syndical
je constate qu'il ya une forme de
radicalité d' aveuglement de refus en
fait de ouvrir un dialogue et de faire
jouer la démocratie sociale dans ce pays
de la part du gouvernement
ce que je constate aussi c'est que la
détermination elle n'est pas simplement
du côté du gouvernement elle est aussi
du côté de celles et de ceux qui
majoritairement aujourd'hui dans le pays
s'opposent à ce projet de réforme qui a
introduit en fait un système à points
qui met fin aux régimes paritaires tel
que nous le connaissons sous prétexte de
lutter contre les les régimes spéciaux
alors qu'ils en créent de nombreux
autres ce que l'on sait et moi je suis
bien placé pour le savoir d'abord j'y
suis né dans ce pays le chili et j'étais
parlementaire des français et abiola et
créative et pays qui ont mis en place ce
type de réforme connaissent des
situations similaires c'est à dire un
appauvrissement général des pensions à
l'appauvrissement général de des
retraités un compteur comment on stoppe
le gouvernement parce que l'équation et
devient extrêmement compliqué la grande
majorité des français 61% veulent le
retrait de ce projet dans le même temps
un forum terme à la mode 56% d'entre eux
demandent la fin de la grève certains
syndicats aujourd'hui cfe cgc demande
une pause or même s'il demande toujours
le retrait mines pause dans la
mobilisation donc c'est ça quand vous
lisez les enquêtes la grèce et c'est un
inconvénient c'est sa force
et depuis plus d'un mois par exemple en
région parisienne les gens en ont pâti
on en fait les références mobiliser ses
difficultés
maintenant que j'ai pour elle c'est que
ce mouvement est assez extraordinaire
vous le voyez dans les images que vous
montrez en ce moment c'est qu'il fait
preuve d'une très grande créativité et
que même si on peut juger en effet que
la grève est à moyens mobilisation qui
peut présenter des problèmes parce que
ça peut souhaiter de la désaffection des
gens qui peuvent en raison des
difficultés rencontrées quotidiennement
sont éloignés
diminuer leurs encouragements ou leur
soutien à aux protestations
ce que je constate moi c'est que ce
mouvement est capable de nouvelles
formes d'action
on voit des retraites aux flambeaux on
voit les avocats par exemple les
danseurs de l'opéra de l'opéra de paris
qui ont offert des spectacles
le choeur de radio france les orchestres
philharmoniques je crois qu'on avait
rarement vu depuis fort longtemps dans
ce pays en france une telle créativité
dans la mobilisation
ce qui veut dire en fait c'est que ce
mouvement même s'il connaît des
difficultés parce que tenir une grève de
plus de 40 jours c'est extrêmement
difficile les gens le pen financièrement
plein de secteurs qui joue un rôle moins
clé en fait dans l'appareil productif
dans le déplacement de nos concitoyens
se mobilisent et se mobilisent avec
leurs armes propres
on le voit quotidiennement dans les
médias sur les réseaux sociaux et c'est
la preuve en fait que la détermination
ne faiblit pas et que le mouvement
s'élargit
merci beaucoup en tout cas sergio
coronado je rappelle que vous êtes
candidat à bondy on aura l'occasion
certainement parler des des municipales
spurs
le ton est un peu fi des très rapidement
voilà un candidat a bondi pour les
municipales merci à vous dans quelques
instants rester avec nous ce sera les
dites aux échos de jacques sapir qui
répondra ce soir à cette question sur le
financement des retraites une conférence
pour quoi faire et puis nous parlerons
de l'accord global entre washington et
paris afin d'éviter toute escalade dans
le conflit qui les oppose à propos d'une
décision française de taxer les
entreprises technologiques
[Musique]
je serai votre sentiment sur les
mouvements concernant la manifestation
contre la retraite quand il ya autant de
travail qui a autant de chômeurs autant
de gens qui sont dans la logique comme
on dit aujourd'hui du burn out
qu'est-ce qu'il n'y aurait pas à
repenser le travail c'est vraiment une
question philosophique pour moi je
défends les gilets jaunes qui sont pour
moi les lieux sous prolétaires je
défends également ces gens là qui pour
le coup ce sont les prolétaires mais qui
sont organisées pourquoi est-ce que
c'est toujours les mêmes qui payent les
pots plus modestes et c est pourquoi ce
sont toujours les mêmes qui échappent
soit à l'impôt soit aux ponctions
d'autres choses qui font que s'il y
avait vraiment un désir de d'équité les
français seraient probablement plus à
même de dire qu'il consente à ce
traitement est ce que vous avez compris
quelle était la revendication au moment
des gilets jaunes tout au départ ce sont
juste des gens qui disent si vous
augmentez le prix du carburant nous on
va pas pouvoir des gens disaient mais
moi je suis chez mes parents parce que
je ne peux pas me payer un loyer alors
que je travaille donc dès le départ
c'était une revendication de dignité
mais vous avez dit on n'a pas écouté ces
gens là comment vouliez vous les écoutez
puisque personne ne prenait la parole et
personne n'était légitime pour
l'apprendre y en a un qui est légitime
pour prendre la parole sur ce sujet là
ça s'appelle un président de la
république parce qu'il est investi de la
souveraineté nationale
en effet l'afghanistan n'est pas un lieu
tranquille ce n'est pas un bon pays
l'afghanistan est un endroit très
dangereux pour quelqu'un de célèbre
[Musique]
abbas est devenu célèbre
avant même de réussir ses amis sur
facebook
ses camarades de classe même des gens
dans la rue et des parents disaient
qu'il ressemblait à bruce lee
chaque fois que quelqu'un m'appelle
rouge qui je suis aux anges
abbas ali se présente comme bruce lee il
imite les actes des infidèles l'islam
dénonce des actes contre la religion
commis par les musulmans
il doit simplement continuer à
s'entraîner peu importe la religion
qu'ils soient musulmans ou non
voilà quelqu'un qui ressemble à bruce
lee qui peut réussir à garder sa mémoire
vivante
cela fera revenir la figure de bruce lee
dans le cinéma et le sport c'est génial
pour la promotion du sport
[Musique]
20h30 heure française merci nous
rejoindre en direct sur rt france elle
les partenaires sociaux au chevet des
retraites la conférence sur leur
financement sera lancé le 30 janvier
prochain
edouard philippe l'a confirmé
aujourd'hui des propositions devront
être faites d'ici au mois d'avril pour
équilibrer les comptes faute de quoi le
gouvernement ressortir à son âge pivot à
64 ans les syndicats peuvent-ils
s'entendre pourquoi est il si urgent en
équilibre et les retraites
on voit ça tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir bonsoir
jacques bienvenue à vous merci c'est à
dire alors jacques et à la feuille de
route est fixé par le gouvernement aux
syndicats les stricts trouver des
solutions sans hausse du coût de travail
ni baisse des pensions est ce qu'il
existe des pistes pour éviter le fameux
h pivot pardon lâche déquilibre ans
qu'elle semble tenir le premier ministre
ali tout à fait parce que on voit bien
que le gouvernement a fixé un cadre
extrêmement contraignant à cette
conférence
alors évidemment edouard philippe tient
à son âge déquilibre ou à son âge pivot
et le medef quand à lui est plus ou
moins sur la ligne des doigts philippe
si ce n'est peut-être le contraire
et quand il déclare qu'il faudra des
mesures justes des mesures d'âge
juste pour assurer le financement à
court moyen et long terme
qu'est ce que sont des mesures d'âge
bien c'est évidemment ce fameux âge
pivot ou h d'équilibré et pourtant en
réalité des solutions outre existe alors
avant d'aller plus loin jacques je me
propose de voir ce qu'en pensent les
français que non
avons rencontré que pensent ils de cette
fameuse conférence et des contraintes
imposées par le gouvernement
ça va être compliqué parce que
visiblement les gens comptent sur la
position que ce soit que ce soit du côté
du gouvernement ou du côté des syndicats
on ne sait pas trop donc s'ils arrivent
à un accord ce sera un petit peu un
miracle
justement c'est ça le problème c'est que
par aman ils sont pas tous d'accord non
plus donc attention il faut que ça
marche ça va marcher et en démocratie il
ya toujours des heures mais à la fin ça
marche toujours et heureusement on est
en 2020 et il va falloir un jour que la
france se met comme les autres pays et
suivent et il y aura fatalement une
méthode à faire sur la durée
d'utilisation soit sur les chevaux soit
il faut équilibrer les comptes c'est ça
reste ça reste une priorité
tout le monde devra un peu contribué
mais que ce soit pas que les salariés ou
que les patrons il fera que tout le
monde fasse des efforts des économies on
profère à plusieurs niveaux sur le
régime des retraites
oui certainement de par la réforme 12 à
17 milliards oui et c'est sans compter
les réserves qui sont déjà mises de côté
donc je pense qu'on pourrait déjà pioché
de ce côté là moi je pense que tous les
gens qui ont travaillé très dur depuis 1
un âge jeune je pense qu'ils vont avoir
une rente est assez anticipées étant
donné qu'on va vite plus longtemps et il
faut effectivement travailler plus
longtemps pour pouvoir payer tout le
monde pas j'ai l'impression que les dés
sont pipés dès le départ donc voyez ça
me parce que j'étais tout à l'heure la
feuille de route elle semble déjà bien
tracé
or est-ce que c'est le gouvernement qui
est vraiment à l'origine et l'impression
que effectivement ils travaillent main
dans la main pour pouvoir nous faire
partir un petit peu plus tard votre
réaction jacques on voit bien que les
français il hésite entre deux positions
tout d'abord il ya des gens qui disent
bon bah voilà nous sommes en démocratie
devrait y avoir normalement un dialogue
social et de ce dialogue devrait sortir
des solutions bien sûr mais il ya les
autres qui div
et bien non les dés sont pipés en
particulier par les contraintes
qu'impose le gouvernement tout ceci ne
marchera pas et même peut-être que il ya
un accord entre certains camps entre
certains syndicats et le gouvernement
alors on l'a dit la conférence qui va
débuter le 30 janvier edouard philippe
l'a confirmé tout d'abord qui va
participer à cette grande réunion
alors pour les syndicats c'est tous les
syndicats que l'on considère comme les
syndicats représentatifs
évidemment il y aura évidemment aussi
les organisations patronales que ce soit
le medef où la cgpme donc qui représente
les petites et moyennes entreprises
et il faut savoir que évidemment en
embuscade il ya toujours le premier
ministre qui est prêt à réintroduire son
âge pivot part dans son âge équilibre si
jamais aucun accord ne peut sortir de
cette conférence alors pourquoi jacques
le gouvernement insiste-t-il sur cette
somme de 12 milliards d'euros à trouver
alors la somme de 12 milliards elle ne
vient pas directement du gouvernement
elle se trouve dans un rapport qui a été
réalisé par le comité
le conseil d'orientation aux retraites
le cor est et qui prévoit effectivement
que vers 2025 2030
il devrait y avoir un déficit pour un
montant de pro probablement 10 à 12
milliards d'euros mais en même temps il
faut savoir qu'il ya un autre rapport
qui lui a été fournie par la cour des
comptes et qui regarde l'ensemble des
contributions patronales qui ont été
annulés par le gouvernement sont que le
gouvernement et compenser cela or
normalement le gouvernement il a
l'obligation légale
chaque fois qu'ils retirent des sommes
du financement de les compenser et là on
voit qu'il y à 50 à 52 milliards d'euros
qui ont été supprimés depuis 2006 c'est
une femme qui est tout à fait
considérable
alors oui normalement il y à bien un
espace de manoeuvre qui est laissée aux
différents partenaires sociaux mais
malheureusement on voit bien que ce
n'est pas dans cette direction que
voudraient s'engager
edouard philippe alors si on vous suit
bien il faudra bien accepter un âge
niveau alors c'est là justement où il
peut y avoir d'autres solutions
parce que il faut savoir que en réalité
ce la question des retraites
eh bien on a déjà une caisse
d'amortissement de la dette sociale et
cette caisse elle est financée par deux
impôts la crds qui est justement
destinée directement à la dette sociale
une partie de la csg il y a aussi le
prélèvement social sur les revenus du
capital qui a été supprimé en 2016 et il
y as enfin les versements du fonds de
réserve pour les retraites ce qu'on
appelle le frr alors globalement ça fait
des ressources tout à fait considérable
vous voyez quand on a au départ en 2004
on est à peu près à 5 milliards d'euros
on aboutit en 2020 à une prévision d'un
petit peu moins de 20 milliards d'euros
et on voit que les deux principaux
piliers de ce financement
eh bien c'est la crds et c'est la csg
alors c'est évidemment quelque chose d'
extrêmement intéressant alors on entend
bien votre argument jacques
mais cet argent est destiné si on a bien
compris à éponger une dette
il n'est donc par conséquent pas
disponibles alors tout à fait vous avez
tout à fait raison
cet argent doit servir à éponger une
dette mais la dette serait épongé en
alors que edouard philippe demande
justement que l' équilibre soit réalisée
en 2027
autrement dit cet argent sera disponible
avant la date prévue
et là il faut savoir que si on regarde
en fait l'évolution
on voit bien là la dette elle est
remboursée en 2024
on voit comment sont montés évidemment
l'ensemble de ces
ressources jusqu'à effectivement
éteindre cette dette
donc qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça veut
dire que à l'horizon 2030 2035
nous aurons effectivement un déficit ou
disons un besoin de financement
complémentaire de 12 à 13 milliards
d'euros mais nous aurons aussi des
ressources par la csg la crds ou le
fonds de réserve des retraites qui
devrait se situer à l'horizon 2030 2035
entre 20 et 22 milliards d'euros il y a
donc plus que assez d'argent mais alors
jacques pourquoi cette obsession sont
ces fameux 12 milliards une obsession
qui risque de faire capoter la
conférence sur le financement des
retraites
vous avez tout à fait raison et il ya
quand même deux raisons à la lune est
une bonne raison effectivement c'est le
problème de l'accroissement de
l'espérance de vie en particulier le
problème de l'espérance de vie en bonne
santé alors on sait que l'espérance de
vie globale attendue à monter 2995 à
2015 elle est montée alors elle reste
plus faible pour les hommes que pour les
femmes helmand par contre ce qui est
intéressant c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé
et là on voit que depuis 2005 2006 cette
espérance de vie stagne et elle stagne
d'ailleurs en deçà des limites d'âge qui
étaient retenus pour l'ach qui vaut ou
l'âge des clips
ce qui veut dire qu'il faudra trouver de
l'argent nécessairement pour financer
grosso modo les dépenses qui sont liées
à la dépendance et on estime qu'à
l'horizon 2030 2035
cela pourrait aller de six à neuf
milliards
bon mais néanmoins par rapport à la
montée des ressources qui était affecté
avant à la cades est salée serait
suffisamment d'argent pour combler le
déficit alors ya une deuxième raison
c'est que le gouvernement il a dans la
tête de faire des réductions d'impôts et
si possible de les faire avant
l'élection présidentielle de 2000 22 or
comme je l' ai dit tout à l'heure la csg
ou la crds ce sont des impôts et donc
et bien cette volonté de procéder à des
des diminutions d'impôt pour des raisons
en réalité électorale qui d'une certaine
manière bloque toute évolution dans le
système donc au final est ce que cette
conférence on peut se poser la question
à ce qu'elle va servir à quelque chose
où est elle
quelque part déjà plié déjà joué alors
en théorie si vous voulez si on était
dans un monde parfait où tous les
acteurs ne regarde que la rationalité
économique
oui normalement on devrait trouver des
solutions on a les moyens de ses
solutions
mais en réalité on voit bien que pour
des raisons politiques
le gouvernement a mis de telles
contraintes sur le système que cette
conférence risque d'aboutir à un échec
et à ce moment là donc fin avril
normalement et bien le premier ministre
pourra revenir sur le devant de la scène
et dire je vous l'avais bien dit il faut
1 h pivot il faut un âge déquilibre
merci jacques pour ses explications qui
nous font réfléchir comme toujours merci
à vous et à très bientôt
les vignerons français selon qui les
grands perdants des négociations sur la
taxe gafa pour tenter de faire reculer
la france sur la fiscalité des géants du
numérique
les etats unis menacent de nouvelles
taxes qui pourrait aller jusqu'à 100 %
sur certains produits français dont les
vins en cause les subventions accordées
par l'union européenne à airbus jugée
déloyale par washington
une mesure qui pèse lourd sur les petits
producteurs qui exportent outre
atlantique que nous sommes allés
rencontrer reportage solène godin avec
dounia thierry vigneron dont le val de
loire depuis plusieurs générations
jacky presse qui a repris le flambeau
familial il y à 50 ans fait vivre en
grande partie son exploitation grâce à
l'exportation vers l'étranger chaque
année c'est un quart de sa production
qui part vers la californie
mais en octobre dernier ce viticulteur
reçoit un email de ses clients
américains
depuis ses ventes aux etats-unis sont
gelés suite aux annonces hier des tarifs
trump sur les 20 de moins de 14 %
d'alcool
s'il vous plaît ne rien étiquetés
et ne pas préparer de commandes pour les
états unis jusqu'à nouvel ordre
plusieurs importateurs en jeu et leur
expédition le temps de comprendre
chercher des solutions et de revoir les
priorités
une conséquence directe des taxes
punitives imposé sur le vin français par
les américains et qui font s'envoler les
tarifs et ralentir les commandes pour ce
viticulteur pris de court par ces
sanctions financières juste avant les
fêtes de fin d'année c'est 20 % de
chiffre d'affaires en moins l'impact est
considérable mais mini inimaginable pour
nous c'est une perte totale des ventes
alors en chiffres ça représente à peu
près 80 mille euros donc c'est énorme
pour nous pour une exploitation comme
nous 80000 euros de pertes de ventes
c'est considérable ce qu'il n'a pas été
porté ça serait s'est perdue des
répercussions financières qui mettent en
péril l'avenir de son exploitation et
des représailles et incomprise par ce
cultivateur
ça nous laisse un peu la bouche amer
parce que en plus nous on subit les
conséquences de
des subventions qui ont été faites pour
l'aéronautique bord airbus tout ça soit
disant qu'il ya eu des grosses
subventions que par l'état et nous on
est prêts subventionnés mais on subit
les conséquences de tout cela donc c'est
quand même c'est pas juste
outre jacky presse c'est tout le secteur
viticole français qui en subit les
conséquences
alors pour le défendre en marge des
négociations entre les gouvernements
français et américain
un député la république en marche de
gironde a décidé de prendre les choses
en main benoît sign on a demandé une
audience à donald trump
pour le moment aucune réponse du
président américain donald trump et
emmanuel macron se sont donné jusqu'à la
fin de l'année pour trouver un accord
des négociations qui laisse un peu de
répit aux vignerons français en pleine
contestation sociale contre la réforme
des retraites blackrock annonce un
vestiaire pour l'environnement lors de
la 50e édition du forum de davos le plus
grand gestionnaire d'actifs du monde à
présenter un fonds d'investissement vert
en partenariat avec la france et
l'allemagne
alors de quoi s'agit-il éléments de
réponse avec nadège abderrazak en france
blackrock jouit d'une mauvaise
réputation le plus grand gestionnaire
d'actifs du monde a en effet été dépeint
comme l'inspirateur cachée du projet de
réforme sur les retraites ce géant
américain j'ai l'équivalent de 7000
milliards de dollars dans le monde et il
vient d'annoncer investir 500 millions
de dollars pour lutter contre le
changement climatique
autant dire une goutte d'eau un
partenariat qui doit mais les capitaux
philanthropique publics et privés bon
allemand il m'est apparu très clairement
que de plus en plus de clients
réfléchissent à la manière dont ils
devraient investir est apparu très
clairement que toute la question du
changement climatique est vraiment lié
aux certitudes ou aux incertitudes
scientifiques
je ne suis pas un scientifique mais de
plus en plus de gens croient en une
forme de science n'est pas en d'autres
av en étant sur le marché des capitaux
depuis maintenant quarante quatre ans il
est très clair que nous sur les marchés
des capitaux
nous allons au devant du risque et nous
n'attendons pas que le risque soit
devant nous et nos partenaires c'est le
nom de ce nouveau fonds d'investissement
plusieurs fondations
la france et l'allemagne ont annoncé
participer à l'initiative
paris et berlin doivent chacun investir
à hauteur de 30 millions de dollars
les défis liés aux changements
climatiques exige de mener des actions
collectives d'envergure ce partenariat
ambitieux contribuera à réorienter les
flux de capitaux vers des
investissements de développement durable
dans les pays émergents et ciblera en
priorité l'afrique
le fonds investira dans des
infrastructures durables comme les
énergies renouvelables l'efficacité
énergétique le stockage d'énergie etc
il ciblera les pays d'asie du sud-est
d'amérique latine et pour au moins 25 %
des investissements les pays d'afrique
blackrock souhaite faire passer ces
investissements durables de 90 milliards
à 1000 milliards d'ici dix ans il compte
aussi se débarrasser des titres publics
deux sociétés qui génèrent plus de 25 %
de leurs revenus à partir de la
production de charbon thermique passer
des paroles aux actes c'est ce
qu'attendent plusieurs ong
mais pour l'heure greenpeace se montrent
sceptiques
les sociétés financières sont
aujourd'hui tout autant responsables que
les industriels des énergies fossiles
blackrock a annoncé qu'ils allaient
réduire leurs financements du charbon
mais ils n'ont pas dit quand ils n'ont
pas inclus d'autres énergies fossiles de
toutes les énergies fossiles le charbon
est la plus néfaste pour la planète pour
espérer limiter le réchauffement à plus
d'1 5 degrés par rapport à l'ère
préindustrielle il faudrait réduire
l'utilisation du charbon de deux tiers
d'ici 2030 est quasiment à zéro en 2050
et c'est plus facile à dire qu'à faire
le greenwashing a donc encore de
beaux jours devant lui la sphère du
diesel gates d'une de nouveau à la une
la fondation des ailes et michel justice
rappelle les français qui s'estiment
lésés par volkswagen à se mobiliser pour
rappel en 2015 on découvrait que près de
11 millions moteur truqués visant à
faire apparaître les émissions
polluantes des véhicules de la marque
ont été vendus les explications de grâce
d'aia le constructeur automobile
volkswagen dans la tourmente
quatre ans après le début du scandale
les consommateurs exigent des indemnités
pour rappel en septembre 2015 le
constructeur allemand reconnaît avoir
vendu aux états unis près de 500 mille
voitures équipées de moteurs truqués
dans le but de dissimuler les émissions
polluantes de leur véhicule
en réalité près de 11 millions étaient
concernés un scandale pour la dette
shalit a dit dont les mérites sont
souvent vanté les marques concernées
sont audi skoda seat et volkswagen pour
faire tomber le premier constructeur
mondial de véhicules dans le monde
les consommateurs ont décidé de se
rassembler la fondation néerlandaise
diesel émission justice lance une action
groupée en france elle appelle toute
personne qui s'estime victime de la
duperie à renseigner son état civil via
un site dédié
objectif donner mandat à l'association
pour le représenter holslag et doit
enfin admettre qu'ils ont menti et ne
pas toujours se contenter de parler du
problème du diesel mais mentir et
tricher ce n'est pas seulement un
problème c'est bien pire qu'un problème
les six en europe les plaignants n'ont
pour le moment pas reçu un centime dans
plusieurs pays du monde
volkswagen a dû payer de lourdes est
dommage mans aux etats unis près de 25
milliards d'euros 80 millions d'euros
pour l'australie et au canada 135
millions ont été versés par la firme au
motif de violation des lois de
l'environnement une industrie allemande
à l'époque exemplaires aujourd'hui
ternie ce scandale a contribué au déclin
du diesel et à favoriser l'attrait pour
l'électrique mais un scandale salutaire
les particules fines émises par les
moteurs diesel génère des problèmes
respiratoires et cardiovasculaires
important pour l'homme
pour fabrice godefroy président de
l'association dédiée et lift de francs
cette affaire a eu beaucoup de
conséquences sur la filière
c'est une démarche qui votent à mon avis
est extrêmement longue
par contre il faut que les consommateurs
prennent aussi en compte que
effectivement peut-être qu'ils vont
avoir des indemnités par rapport à ça
mais par contre derrière cette affaire
de diesel gate est une problématique
pour eux derrière parce que derrière
qu'est-ce qu'on a eu on a eu les
augmentations des prix des carburants
sous sous cette forme là en se servant
en fait de cet argument là on a les
restrictions et les zones de faibles
émissions alors qu'ils ne touchent pas
que le diesel parce que souvent on dit
on va interdire le diesel en 2024 mais
il faut quand même pas oublier qu'à
paris par exemple madame hidalgo annoncé
qu'en 2030 ce sera aussi la fin du
moteur thermique thermique ça veut dire
quoi
diesel essence et hybrides donc c'est
très important
donc faut faire attention parce que dans
ce genre de démarche qui est finalement
issu d'une triche d'un constructeur ça a
touché l'ensemble d'une filière
et comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure ça
touche aussi tous les consommateurs et
ce à des répercussions extrêmement
importante
il faut faire bien attention parce que
quand on fait par exemple une
restriction oatmeal de véhicules qui ne
pourront plus roulé qui ont été achetés
alors que la carte grise
jusqu'à preuve du contraire n'avait pas
une date de péremption ça veut dire
qu'on est en train de créer une
obsolescence programmée sur les
véhicules
donc tout ça c'est des répétitions qui
sont quand même très important il faut
faire très attention et alors que la
tempête gloria sévit dans le sud de la
france depuis le début de la semaine un
rapport du ministère de la transition
écologique et solidaire tire la sonnette
d'alarmé sur l'augmentation des risques
climatiques en france les explications
en images
[Musique]
ans
on
et puis au royaume uni après le
parlement c'est la reine elizabeth ii
qui a approuvé le projet du break site
aujourd'hui un accord qui donne au
projet force de loi à huit jours du
départ de l'union européenne le traité
de retrait doit encore être ratifié par
le parlement européen cette fois le 29
janvier pour être promulgué
définitivement c'est le vice président
de la chambre des communes qui a annoncé
la nouvelle aujourd'hui 300 je dois
informer la chambre que conformément à
la loi de 1967 sur la sanction royale
sa majesté a accordé sa sanction royale
à la loi suivante loi de 2020 sur
l'accord de retrait de l'union
européenne
le portable du patron d'amazon at il été
piraté par l'arabie saoudite le prince
héritier mohammed bin salman pourraient
être impliqués dans la surveillance de
jeff bezos ce et hier des experts de
l'onu ont réclamé une enquête
alors que ryad considère ces allégations
absurde
charlotte fraîche et pour les
explications
c'est une affaire d'espionnage hors
norme elle concerne l'arabie saoudite
désignés responsables du piratage du
téléphone du patron d'amazon jeff bezos
c'est en tout cas ce qu'affirme agnès
callamard rapporteur spécial pour les
exécutions extrajudiciaires aux nations
unies selon elle le prince héritier
serait lui même impliqué dans cet acte
de piratage
we found date de mon iphone os
nous avons constaté que le téléphone
portable de monsieur b dos a été piraté
en avril mai 2010huit qu'il a
probablement été piratés via un fichier
vidéo envoyée sur what's app à partir
d'un compte appartenant au prince
héritier d'arabie saoudite y mit
immédiatement après avoir reçu ce
fichier vidéo le téléphone a commencé à
fonctionner de manière complètement
différente par rapport à d'habitude est
un exemple de ce dysfonctionnement
le très grand nombre de données qui ont
été exfiltrés hors du téléphone number
of jeff bezos avait affirmé en avril
dernier que l'arabie saoudite avait
piraté son téléphone pour avoir accès à
ses données personnelles d accusation
que dément formellement ryad
ce que je peux dire c'est que ces
allégations sont complètement fausses et
qu'elles reposent sur des conjectures et
les informations incomplètes
il n'y a aucune preuve réelle que nous
puissions voir et donc vous savez nous
pensons que ce n'est pas du tout une
accusation sérieux propriétaire du
washington post
jeff bezos s'employer jamal khashoggi
journalistes saoudiens et critique
envers ryad qui avait été assassiné au
consulat d'arabie saoudite à istanbul en
une affaire largement couverte par le
journal américain considéré selon un
enquêteur privé engagé par le pdg
d'amazon comme un ennemi majeur de la
monarchie saoudienne
les conclusions de l enquête d experts
de l'onu doivent quant à elles être
rendu public en juin prochain
dans quelques instants nous reviendrons
sur les commémorations à jérusalem des
75 ans de la libération d'auschwitz avec
une quarantaine de chefs d'état réunis
et puis nous parlerons des conclusions
du rapport de loyat c'est sur la taxe
chimiques présumées de douma ont s'il
restait
[Musique]
et
oui
[Musique]
et honnêteté je peux faire pousser
jusqu'à dix mille pieds de coca sur un
hectare parce qu'il pousse proches les
uns des autres
beaucoup de gens disent que la coca est
mauvaise mais nos autres paysans qui la
cultiveront pour survivre on ne ne
traitons pas comme un ennemi
[Musique]
le score les fermiers dans tous les
colombiens sont obligés de détruire les
plantations illégales et la culture de
la coca est interdite en colombie
[Applaudissements]
il envoie l'armée avec des fusils et des
matraques pour déraciner la coca que
nous plantons ok c'est le cas je ne suis
pas un dealer je ne travaille pour aucun
carton je cultive la coca pour survivre
lien s'il ne m'en réjouis pas cassé
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
alexandre je faisais direct vous êtes
vous déjà dopé
il n'y a jamais de ma vie je vous
pensiez que la sphère du dopage en
russie était terminée pour vous trompiez
le document sont arrivés et que j'ai
ouvert le dossier et j'ai eu
l'impression d'être recouverts de boue
la participation des athlètes russes aux
compétitions internationales est en jeu
cela concerne notamment des événements
tels que les jeux olympiques de tokyo et
la coupe du monde de football au qatar
c'est ma médaille je sais que je les
gagne honnêtement je ne la vendrai
jamais comme il ya quatre ans le
laboratoire antidopage de moscou est au
centre de ce scandale
l'or qui a modifié la base de données
d'échantillons des sportifs et quel
rapport cela a t-il avec grigoriy
rodtchenko ils ont pu remplacer des
résultats négatifs par des résultats
positifs comme si l'athlète avait déjà
consommé des substances interdites pour
l'approcher par la suite et le faire
chanter pour de l'argent
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs sont joués mais les
mecs ne sont pas toujours respectées les
couleurs changent de camp les pions
prennent la place des rois de films
stratégies peuvent porter des résultats
inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire je suis relax au maire et
chaque semaine dans l'échiquier mondial
nous analyserons les coups les plus
complexes du jeu politique
internationale
[Musique]
à bientôt sur rt france
yelle parfois on n'a que des
éléphanteaux victimes de braconnage
particulièrement brutale car
malheureusement les bébés sont souvent
témoin non seulement du meurtre de leur
mère mais aussi la voix se faire
massacrer des coupes et une brochette
[Musique]
radio je crois que les éléphants
sourient
c'est ce que je vois chez des petits
leurs expressions faciales change
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous 21h heure française merci
de nous rejoindre pour cette deuxième
heure d'émission est tout de suite voici
les titres de l'actualité de ce jeudi
le 5e forum international sur la shoah
s'est tenue aujourd'hui à jérusalem
de très nombreux dirigeants présents
dont vladimir poutine emmanuel macron
encore mike pence
une journée pour se souvenir également
des soldats de l'armée rouge libérateur
du camp d'auschwitz ce matin le camp le
président russe a assisté à
l'inauguration d'un monument consacré à
ceux qui ont subi le siège de linkedin
et ran on en parle dans quelques
instants avec mon invité le projet de
réforme des retraites est présenté en
conseil des ministres demain avant
d'arriver au parlement début février une
étape clé pour une réforme contestée
depuis maintenant 50 jours sur la forme
sur le fond le projet divise et
notamment les syndicats si l'âge pivot a
été retiré provisoirement les dés sont
ils jetés pour autant la réforme
suivra-t-elle son cours quoi qu'il
arrive ce sera l'objet d'un autre face à
face dans 30 minutes
[Musique]
et
j'en ai mémorielle donc notamment pour
se souvenir de la libération du camp
d'auschwitz était le 27 janvier il ya
tout juste soixante quinze ans et
dirigeants du monde entier tête à
jérusalem pour participer au forum
mondial de la shoah retour sur cette
journée avec rania berrada c'est la
première fois qu'un président français
vient se recueillir devant ce mur des
noms un mur où sont inscrits les
patronymes origines date et lieu de
déportation de 73 1853 juifs envoyés
dans les combles et puis la france
devant la communauté française d'israël
emmanuel macron a tenu à rassurer en
condamnant fermement la résurgence de
l'antisémitisme en france
l'antisémitisme revient pas ces derniers
mois non vous savez bien ces dernières
années il est là son cortège
d'intolérance de haine et je sais
combien ici toutes et tous vous êtes
déterminés à mes côtés mais je vais vous
le dire très clairement la france n'aura
pas ce visage et l'antisémitisme
j'ai eu là aussi l'occasion de le dire à
plusieurs reprises ça ne doit pas être
uniquement ni même d'abord le problème
des juifs l'antisémitisme en france
c'est d'abord et avant tout le problème
de la république dans le même temps le
président russe inauguré aux côtés de
benyamin nétanyahou et de revel rivlin
un mémorial en hommage aux victimes du
siège de leningrad par les nazis pendant
la seconde guerre mondiale l'occasion
pour le premier ministre de l'état
hébreu de rappeler le rôle prépondérant
de l'armée rouge verso nous ne devons
pas oublier le sacrifice et la
contribution de l'ex union soviétique
ces nations et des soldats de l'armée
rouge à la défaite du monstre nazi et au
sauvetage du monde d'une tragédie
affreuse
nous nous souviendrons toujours des
soldats de l'armée rouge qui ont ouvert
les portes de 75 ans ont passé et la
leçon et puissamment gravé en nous pas
de compromis avec des régimes fanatiques
qui ont une idéologie impitoyable ils
doivent être stoppés à temps benyamin
nétanyahou vladimir poutine emmanuel
macron ensuite retrouvé une quarantaine
de dirigeants mémorial de yad vashem
pour prendre part au 5e forum de la
shoah pendant son discours le président
russe a rendu hommage aux hommes et aux
femmes qui ont donné leur vie pour
libérer l'europe du nazisme
à l'époque en 1945 le peuple soviétique
a mis fin aux plans barbare il a comme
cela a été dit ici défendu sa patrie et
permis à l'europe de se libérer du
nazisme
nous l'avons payé à un prix qu'aucune
nation n'avait imaginé dans ses pires
cauchemars 27 millions de morts
nous n'oublierons jamais cela le
souvenir de l'holocauste ne sera une
leçon est un avertissement que s'il est
complet sans exemple sur owni omission
malheureusement aujourd'hui la mémoire
de la guerre ses enseignements et le
patrimoine
s'ils deviennent de plus en plus l'objet
de la spéculation politique c'est chase
était absolument inacceptable et le
devoir des politiciens actuels et futurs
des hommes d'état et personnalités
publiques et de protéger la réputation
des héros gigean et disparus des civils
par des victimes des nazis et de leurs
complices
le président russe qui a également
appelé les cinq membres permanents du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu à se réunir
afin de défendre et préserver la paix
vadimir poutine s'est dit prêt à
organiser cette rencontre en russie et
pour parler de ce forum de la shoah et
de la deuxième guerre mondiale nous
sommes avec marie montier bits en
historienne hauteur de la shoah dans les
territoires soviétique occupés aux
éditions persée composé pour soir marie
vautier mi temps on va aborder avec vous
peut-être un pan de 7,2
guerre mondiale qui n'est pas connu
nécessairement par tout le monde
nous sommes donc en 1941 en pleine
opération barbarossa la shoah commençant
territoire soviétique
expliquez-nous comment cela se met en
place
alors dès le 22 juin 1941 des premiers
massacres de juifs commence dans les
territoires soviétique occupés et
contrairement à l'ouest ce sont les
bourreaux qui vont aller aux victimes et
non l'inversé
c'est à dire que des milliers de sites
d'exécution vont se déployer à l'est des
unités mobiles dont les einsatzgruppen
vont massacrer plus d'un tiers des
victimes de la shoah
alors quand vous nous parlez de enza ce
groupe end ce sont des commando
d'assassins
c'est bien cela explique mais nous qui
sont ils
alors ils sont environ 3000 répartis en
quatre groupes
le premier groupe qui va balayer les
pays baltes et se rendre jusqu à
leningrad
le deuxième qui lui va massacrer les
juifs de biélorussie
le troisième et le quatrième le sait le
dès qu'ils vont massacrer les juifs
d'ukraine et c'est finalement c'est 3000
hommes vont tuer +22 je dirais 1100
milles
personne en même pas un an alors ils
sont hors de l'armée sézanne stan groupe
tout en étant partie de l'armée tout en
faisant partie de l'armée d'occupation
alors il sort alors ils sont
indépendants de l'armée bien entendu ils
doivent envoyer des rapports avec à la
wehrmacht pour être sûr qu'ils ne vont
pas empiéter sur les terrains
d'opérations militaires
mais sinon ils ont toute autonomie pour
tuer les opposants d inique auparavant
par heydrich et himmler qui sont leurs
chèvres et directe et qui vont leur
désigner les juifs les communistes les
membres du parti communiste comme les
premières cibles dont qui en en gros ils
obéissent finalement au même ordre que
les ss c'est ça tout à fait ils
appartiennent au rsa chat qui est
directement présidée par reinhard
heydrich et leur mission est
véritablement d'éliminer tous les
opposants de l'arrière front les
premières victimes seront des hommes
juifs massivement mais dès le mois
d'août 1941 des femmes et des enfants
juifs vont faire partie des victimes
et je dirais qu'à partir de septembre
octobre 1941 les massacres de juifs
des familles entières sera systématique
à l'est alors pour avoir une vision
globale des choses à combien de morts
estime-t-on la choix en union soviétique
occuper 10 ans entre 2 et 2,5 millions
de juifs ont été tués sur ces
territoires
alors avec quels moyens et quel objectif
la politique génocidaire nazis s'est
elle mise en place à ce moment là est ce
que l'armée et a pris une place bien
entendu la wehrmacht a fourni un appui
logistique considérable aux alsace
gruppen mais il ya aussi les bataillons
de police qui ont participé et comme
vous pouvez l'imaginer les populations
locales la police locale et une main
d'oeuvre très importante a été
réquisitionné pour creuser les fausses
combler les fossés transportait les
victimes jusqu'au site d'exécution
c'était toute une organisation vous
imaginez à l'échelle d'un territoire
pour tuer 2 5 millions de juifs alors à
partir de 1942 se met en place
l'opération
1005 expliquez-nous ce que sait quel est
son objectif
à partir de janvier 1942 les soviétiques
commence à parler dans la presse des
massacres commis par les par les nazis
du côté des allemands se rend compte que
les cadavres dans les fosses communes
peuvent être un véritable outil de
propagande pour les soviétiques et il
donnerait une image désastreuse de
l'allemagne en pleine guerre si les
soviétiques venait à découvrir ces
charniers c'est pour ça qu'à partir de
janvier 42 on va missionner un ancien
membre des commandos paul blobel pour
trouver une solution
il va mener une politique de des termes
en décor et ensuite ces corps seront
brûlées dans d'immenses muchez par des
commandos composé de main d'oeuvre juive
qui sont bien entendu exécuté par la
suite mais tous les charniers n'ont pas
été ouverts et détruit pour beaucoup ils
sont
ils ont profité de la vence de l'armée
rouge et ont pu être préservés et
ensuite l'armée rouge a pu faire état de
ces fosses communes alors l'ennemi vous
le dites dans votre livre c'est dès le
mois de juin 1941 le judéo bolchevisme
un beau bébé dit tout à l'heure c'est à
dire que dès le début de l'opération
barbarossa dont on parlait l'armée
d'occupation allemande confond un mode
de gouvernement avec avec une religion
alors disons que dès le départ les
soldats les membres des instances
européennes de bataille de police savent
clairement que l'ennemi c'est les juifs
parce que les juifs gouvernent l'union
soviétique et en s'en prenant aux juifs
on va s'en prendre finalement aux
fondements mêmes de l'union soviétique
qui devrait s'effondrer
finalement pourquoi on parle très peu de
ce pan de l'histoire on parle on connaît
davantage une autre partie de l'histoire
et peut justement ces morts sur le
territoire de l'union soviétique à la
raison pendant des décennies ces
archives n'ont pas été accessibles pour
les chercheurs de l'ouest mais à la
faveur de la chute de l'union soviétique
nous avons pu avoir accès à des
centaines de milliers de pages des
archives qui ont été produits par
l'union soviétique notamment par une
commission denquête créé en 1942 chargé
de documenter tous ces crimes commis à
l'est dont chaque village et cette
commission a permis de documenter
vraiment des crimes de l'est et comment
vous les avez trouvés tous ces documents
savent bien que les nazis effectivement
faisait le récit leur massacre dans des
ondées récit dans des alors quelques
rapports des einsatzgruppen nous sont
parvenues mais disons que toutes les
archives officielles ont été quasiment
détruites
en revanche chez nous est restée les
correspondances intimes
les photographies personnelles en fait
tous les documents personnels pour
beaucoup ont été récupérés par l'armée
rouge lors de la libération des villes
quelle a été la réaction des autorités
soviétiques après la guerre est ce qu il
des procès comme évidemment celui qu'on
connaît très bien le procès de nuremberg
gains qu'il y à eut alors on juger mais
oui de l'année 1943 alors que la guerre
est loin d'être finie à krasnodar se
tient le premier procès de
collaborateurs nazis
ils sont jugés pour trahison et il y
aura jusqu'à la chute de l'union
soviétique 250000 condamnation de
collaborateurs aujourd'hui est-ce que ce
devoir de mémoire qui a également en
europe avec la shoah on la retrouve
également dans ces pays qui ont eu ces
morts je dirais que ce cette mémoire est
aussi associée aux autres victimes du
nazisme sur ce territoire qu'elle ne
faut pas oublier que les populations
locales et les prisonniers de guerre ont
payé un très lourd tribut de la guerre
et de l'occupation nazie par exemple un
biélorusse sur trois a été tué pendant
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale il
faut replacer aussi des choses dans le
contact aujourd'hui il ya une vraie
éducation / sur ce point dans les livres
d'histoire de ces pays là disons que
dans certains pays comme la biélorussie
on entretient véritablement cette
mémoire les lieux les sites d'exécution
son mémorial ise je savais que les
choses sont plutôt bien fait
merci beaucoup marie gautier mutanda me
reste avec nous en direct sur rt france
mercière il réunion à la demande de la
russie s'est tenue à l'onu à new york le
20 janvier l'objectif était de discuter
de l'intégrité de l'équipe de l'oas
ayant enquêté sur la taxe chimiques
présumées de douma en avril 2018
contestée par les représentants russes
un ancien expert de l'oif s'est déjà
cité par wikileaks est intervenu pour
réfuter la version finale de l' enquête
est les explications de katia technique
nouveau rebondissement dans le dossier
sur la taxe chimiques présumées de douma
en syrie en 2018
le 20 janvier dernier une réunion du
conseil de sécurité en formule arria a
été demandée par moscou lors de cet
échange informel vassili n'est benzia
représentant permanent de la russie
a souhaité remettre en question le
rapport de l'organisation pour
l'interdiction des armes chimiques sur
la taca douma le 7 avril 2018 un
bombardement attribué par l'occident aux
troupes de bachar al-assad avait
entraîné la mort de quelques dizaines de
personnes
les pays occidentaux avaient soupçonné
une utilisation d'agents chimiques
l'incident avaient entraîné des frappes
le 13 avril de la part des etats-unis de
la france et du royaume uni sur le
centre de recherche de barzé en syrie
les experts de l'oit ac avaient mené
leur enquête puis publié un court
document préliminaire en juillet 2018
les enquêteurs n'avaient pas trouvé de
traces de gaz sarin mais de produits
chimiques chlorés
après des investigations complémentaires
le rapport final en mars 2019 a statué
ce produit chimique contenait un réactif
du chlore le produit toxique était
vraisemblablement dû clore moléculaire
mais des documents révélés par wikileaks
depuis octobre 2019 ont dévoilé qu'un
ancien expert de loyat c'est ian
henderson avait exprimé des doutes sur
une des analyses du rapport concernant
des cylindres après avoir collecté des
informations sur les lieux du
bombardement
mais il ne faisait pas partie des
experts retenus pour la mission la ffm
laquelle ne lui a jamais demandé d'
expertise ian henderson a ensuite
expliqué à des membres de l'onu que le
rapport final constitue un revirement
par rapport aux observations de l'équipe
sur place
les conclusions du rapport final de la
ffm étaient contradictoires était un
revirement complet de ce que l'équipe
avait collectivement déduit pendant et
suivant les enquêtes à la douma et au
moment de la publication du rapport
intermédiaire
notre avis était que nous avions de
sérieux doutes sur le fait qu'une
attaque chimique est eu lieu si l'on
excepte henderson aucun membre de
l'équipe de terrain a contredit
jusqu'ici le rapport
mais ian henderson reproche à la ffm de
n'avoir pas tenu compte des remarques
contradictoires de son rapport
balistique qui l'a envoyé à l'équipe la
veille de la publication du document
final
le rapport n'a pas fait toute la lumière
sur les nouvelles découvertes
informations données ou analyses dans le
domaine des témoignages des études
toxicologiques des analyses chimiques
des études d'ingénierie et de balistique
et en définitive a produit un revirement
complet par rapport à ce que la majorité
de l'équipe et l'équipe entière de la
douma penser en juillet 2018
[Applaudissements]
en ce qui me concerne j'ai poursuivi
pendant six mois une étude balistique et
d'ingéniérie sur les cylindres qui m'ont
conduit à donner davantage de crédit au
fait qu'il n'y ait pas les attaques
ciblant le rapport de l'oif s'est fait
toutefois mention d' analyses
balistiques indépendante de trois pays
affirmant que les cylindres sont bien
tombés du ciel
plusieurs membres du conseil de sécurité
ont débattu du témoignage de jan
andersson chacun restant sur ses
positions
oui mais nous devons défendre la
crédibilité et les conclusions de loyat
c'est ainsi que les nations unies contre
la désinformation
chamand crise certains pays guidé par
les états unis continuent d'outrepasser
les dispositions de la convention sur
l'interdiction des armes chimiques en
politisant le travail de loyat c est en
s'écartant de la voix pour laquelle elle
a été créée dirrell franck de traque les
toise qu'il y ait toutefois alexander
shulgin représentant de la russie auprès
de l'organisation pour l'interdiction
des armes chimiques
interroge la crédibilité de l'organisme
et a suggéré une solution que nous
proposons une fois de plus de résoudre
ce différend en organisant une rencontre
avec le jass et avec l'aide possible d
état membre requérant la participation
de tous les membres de la ffm qui ont
travaillé sur le rapport de la dgs main
afin de parvenir enfin à un consensus
sur le sujet de l'incident survenu dans
la ville syrienne des liasses et qui a
décliné l'invitation à cette réunion a
publiquement peu défendu les conclusions
du rapport dont elle dit qu'il se bat
sur des analyses scientifiques
concordantes
et alors que les spéculations émergent
seuls les représentants de cet organisme
pourrait enfin mettre fin à la
controverse en acceptant de s'exprimer
tri pour parler nous sommes en direct
depuis alep avec pierre le corre
président de l' ong without you were
here aux bonsoir pierre le kof merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
on précise pour nos téléspectateurs
calais puis à une coupure d'électricité
ceci explique l'obscurité dans laquelle
vous vous trouvez mais rassurez vous on
vous voit quand même merci à vous en
tout cas d'être en direct avec nous tout
d'abord pourquoi autant de confusion et
de contradictions sur ce sujet parce
qu'il est évident que le rapport initial
a été entièrement biaisé par la suite
c'est à dire que ce qui est écrit au
départ par l'équipe qui a enquêté sur la
pac qui est élu à douma a été
entièrement modifiée ce qui a été
ensuite relayé souligné par un des
enquêteurs qui n'a pas compris ce qui
était en train d'arriver par rapport à
son rapport aux finalement énormément de
fer à bd soit totalement manipulée soit
totalement écrasée t il ya une chose que
finalement les gens ne n'arrive pas à
comprendre qu'ils ne peuvent pas
vraiment savoir sans attrition syrie
c'est le fait que les attaques chimiques
qui a eu lieu que ce soit en 2017 en
2018 n'ont pas pu être justifiée étant
même en 2017 à l'époque de ranchs et 12
n'ont pas pu être justifié par le
gouvernement français ni par le
gouvernement américain ni par
l'organisation est à sec
malheureusement à travers des les
documents jusqu'à maintenant ils ont
attesté avoir des preuves suffisantes
mais sans justifier de ses preuves donc
pour moi aujourd'hui il ya simplement
une tentative de légitimisation des
attaques qui ont eu lieu et
légitimisation finalement d'une
propagande pure et dure contre la syrie
contre lens cette affaire on le sait est
forcément éminemment politique est très
sensible chacun peut-être s'accusent de
manipulation finalement qui peut-on
croire et sur quels fonds non ce qui est
très difficile en fait ce qu il faudrait
que les personnes pakistan qui
s'intéressent réellement à au sujet de
la syrie est ce qui se passe aux gens
qui vivent aux gens qui souffrent face
leurs droits
recherche finalement il ya énormément de
personnes qui se sont mobilisées pour
faire des recherches complémentaires
tant par rapport aux attaques chimiques
qui ont eu lieu à reims les routes à la
douma où même à alep l'année dernière
puisque nous avons été bombardés et nous
avons été bombardés pendant toute la
guerre par des armes chimiques mais par
les terroristes c'est à dire que nous
nous recevions ici des des obus et des
roquettes qui était rempli de chlorine
et ça on n'y a assisté l'année et
l'année dernière encore nous avons été
bombardés ici avec la plupart des
personnes qui ont assisté à la
libération ont pu découvrir des centres
entier de des munitions avec des
centaines de sacs de chlorine qui
venaient directement d'arabie saoudite
alors certains vont dire que c'est une
théorie du complot et cetera c'est
impossible évidemment c'est le
gouvernement qui a fait ça chacun ira de
sa de son propre roman mais la réalité
sur le terrain les différentes et chacun
si vous faites des recherches même là le
reporter en chef qui était en charge de
l'enquêté sur la taxe chimiques de douma
a totalement remis en question de la bbc
a remis en question fait la tête chemise
en disant eu les vidéos au sein de
l'hôpital ont été entièrement mises en
scène et que d'ailleurs la principale
personne qui filmait la vidéo sans
qu'elle aboubakar annan est l'un des
principaux membres de touche à l'islam
l'armée l'armée de l'islam
donc c'est très difficile finalement de
faire la part des choses
mais ce qui est évident c'est
qu'aujourd'hui ces rapports et et ce qui
était arrivé n'ont rien à voir avec avec
la réalité sont là alors il ya des
personnes on en parle depuis tout à
l'heure inspecteurs de l'organisation
pour l'interdiction des armes chimiques
a pointé du doigt des conclusions
contradictoires on l'a dit
concrètement de quoi s'agit-il il est
pas mal d'arguments principalement le
fait que les analyses chimiques ne
permettent pas vraiment de relever les
composants qui ont pu être utilisés
second ternant principalement le fait
qu'il n'y ait pas balistique mme en
parlant de preuve que ces cylindres soit
arrivée du ciel
et plus encore important il n'y a aucune
preuve qu'il y a eu une utilisation
chimiques à partir de sept cylindres
donc il ya eu des relevés chimiques qui
ont eu lieu sur ces cylindres mais il
n'y a aucune preuve comme quoi c'est
chirac ces cylindres auraient été les
objets qui ont délivré une prétendue
attaque chimique
à la fin la réalité c'est que le
l'enquêteur en question qui a remis en
cause les éléments de réécriture du
rapport signifie très clairement que le
rapport ne représente que le plus du
tout le travail d enquête qui a été
réalisée en amont et au départ après l'
attaque
il n'y a pas aujourd'hui de preuve
suffisants pour pouvoir justifier de
l'attak moi si je devais pouvoir en
parler aujourd'hui en tant que personne
en tant qu'humanitaires qui est ici il y
à quelque chose qui est arrivé c'est
certain qu'est ce qui est arrivé comment
on pack je pense jamais réellement le
savoir
par contre il ya une chose qui est
réelle c'est que jusqu'à maintenant il
est évident et jolie et c'est un risque
que je prends le dise en tant qu' en
tant que français c'est que il est
évident que le gouvernement syrien ni le
gouvernement russes n'ont aucun intérêt
à utiliser l'un d'eux chimiques contre
la population en syrie
en tout cas effectivement ces propos
n'engagent que vous vous le dites
vous-même vous prenez un risque en
disant ça qui est selon vous en tout cas
cet ancien d'inspecteurs est on certain
de son indépendance pour les
téléspectateurs qui nous regardent
évidemment il y a beaucoup de personnes
aujourd'hui qui se sont manifestées
comme lui comme la personne finalement
qui a écrit un anonyme anonymisées par
le biais de wikileaks wikileaks a libéré
des emails qui permettait de justifier
que l'un des principaux enquêteurs a
réduit finalement retraduit le texte
initial en soulignant qu'il y a des
paragraphes qui ont été clairement
effacés et qu'il y a les tournures de
phrases qui ont été clairement modifié
c'est à dire que cet enquêteur
aujourd'hui qui tient à souligner
finalement les éléments qui ont été
retracés par l'enquêteur initial de la
douma nous
reprendre des éléments de preuves qui
ont été constatés par une personne parmi
une équipe qui était présente sur le
site de la douma et qui a analysé c'est
à ces éléments tant balistique
scientifique et cette affaire c'est à
dire qu' il n'y a pas possibilité de
remettre en question le témoignage de
quelqu'un qui était sur place qui a
analysé le terrain qui a interviewé les
habitants c'est c'est difficile
aujourd'hui que de remettre en question
entre guillemets les éléments qui sont
plus que probants à travers le texte et
surtout de voir la différence entre le
rapport initial et le rapport est écrit
le rapport est écrit il laisse la
possibilité légitime qu'il y ait une
attaque chimique le rapport initial
laisse clairement sous entendent qu'il
n'y a aucune chimie d'utilisation à 2,12
origine de tout élément qui pourrait
être chic
merci merci pierre le corre d'avoir été
avec nous en direct depuis allaitent
merci à vous nous avoir exprimé en tout
cas votre opinion
donc quelques instants rester avec nous
notre débat sur le projet de réforme des
retraites présenté en conseil des
ministres ce vendredi avant d'arriver au
parlement début février une étape clé
pour une réforme contestée depuis
cinquante jours et qui divise les
syndicats on en débattra
[Musique]
dans ce livre on vous découvre
extrêmement proche de votre mari un
couple très fusionnelle est-ce que vous
viviez un peu dans la peur avec tino
quai des menaces oui d intimidation
comme brûler les locaux oui mais un
assassinat vraiment jeune ans je pense
que j'y croyais pas ceux qui ont été
assassinés étaient les politiques du
journal il était l'âme de ce journal et
oui ils ont tué charlie je voulais pas
que tignes où ce soit une victime
je voulais pas que son nom soit associé
à 8 in youth la victime de charlie je
voulais que l'on se dise à tignes où le
grand dessinateur c'est ça qui est bien
avec un artiste c'est qu'un artiste tant
qu'on publie son travail l'artiste est
vivant
[Musique]
j'ai fort potentiel programme moi et je
ferai que ce que je sois tu es un gros
beauf moon et des êtres humains
je vous emmène découvrir les robots les
plus high tech qui vont bientôt sortir
de leur laboratoire pour rentrer dans
nos maisons
[Musique]
l'ère des robots approche nous avons
l'opportunité de pouvoir changer le
monde
ceux-ci excitant ils vont changer notre
manière de nous divertir d'apprendre de
communiqué en fait il y avait changé
notre vie
[Musique]
les news ne s'arrête jamais mais c'est
votre soutien que nous apprécions le
plus
[Musique]
on a construit
attention attention la tête mais qu'est
ce qui fait que nous allons découvrir le
meilleur de kerk on a construit ça doit
être bon
attention on a construit et le bon tu le
vois oui il est en construction on la
construit avec six mois d'avancé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
loïc et geoffroy de l'aftu les sont deux
frères explorateurs animés par une
passion commune l'eau
[Musique]
pour leur cinquième expédition ils ont
choisi de sillonner l'amérique du sud en
side-car à la rencontre des populations
locales
en cinq mois de la vie de sao paulo a
soif et à la terre de feu
inhabitée ils ont parcouru plus de 14
mille kilomètres motivés par cette
question
notre usage de l'eau témoins utiles de
notre lien la nature
[Musique]
arrimé des pays africains à l'euro c'est
une évidence bêtise la france a intérêt
à maintenir de français va parce que
c'est long mais c'est leur instrument
qui sont la protection de ses intérêts
économiques en afrique
l'écho c'est quelque chose qui était
fait entre pays africains et sur lequel
la france et l'europe avait pas grand
chose à dire en question au ladakh fixe
avait dit non mais c'est est ce que
c'est la même monnaie
le sujet aujourd'hui en afrique c'est
pas d'avoir une inflation à 2%
ces espèces de critères qu'on impose
alors c'est des critères de qui a entre
guillemets d'économies matures à des
économies qui sont en développement
studio
[Musique]
votre honneur 30 soyez les bienvenus en
direct sur arte france merci de nous
rejoindre une manifestation une autre
contre la réforme des retraites se
dérouler ce soir à paris et la lumière
des flambeaux départ de la place de la
nation pour aboutir à la place de la
république
notre reporter guillemin rossi est sur
place le cortège vient d'arriver ici
place de la république ce sont entre
1000 et 2000 personnes qui ont participé
ce soir à cette marche aux flambeaux qui
est parti donc de la place de la nation
en passant par le cimetière du père
lachaise
l'objectif de cette mobilisation était
double prouver que la contestation
contre la réforme des retraites est
toujours bien vivante et dénoncer
symboliquement la mise à mort du système
de retraite actuel telle mise à mort
d'un modèle social de la société
française qui a fait ses preuves depuis
plus de 70 ans
un système basé sur la solidarité qui
est largement finançables aujourd'hui au
vu des profits monstrueux que produisent
jaillir les salariés en france et les
travailleurs françaises et français et
donc effectivement c'est y veulent rayer
un modèle de société
l'issue du conseil national de la
résistance et qui a fait toutes ses
preuves en france et nous pousser vers
une capitalisation à l'anglo saxonne qui
va pousser des millions de français dans
la pauvreté et la précarité
cette opération a été organisée par
l'intersyndicale au sein de laquelle on
compte par exemple la cgt force ouvrière
ou encore solidaire c'est près d'une
dizaine de syndicats qui ont appelé à
manifester aujourd'hui
mais parmi cette liste que je viens
d'égrainer vous aurez sans doute noté un
grand absent la cfdt la cfdt qui a
choisi il y à peu la voie du compromis
et de la discussion avec l'exécutif
la cfdt on n'a pas vu depuis le mois de
décembre très clairement contrairement à
95 puisque j'ai l'âge d'avoir été aussi
manifestants et grévistes en 1995 où une
partie la cfdt n'est présent la très
clairement elle a été invisible donc on
n'attend pas on ne compte pas sur la
cfdt
et puis je crois qu'il a été
montrer qu'une partie des conseillers de
la cfdt étaient les mêmes que ceux qui
avaient pu conseiller macron donc voilà
c'est le choix de ce syndicat qui est à
côté on peut avoir du mal à comprendre
du mouvement qui se dessine dans ce pays
on vient également d'apprendre que la
cfe cgc a annoncé vouloir faire une
pause dans son mouvement de grève après
la mobilisation de demain en cause ses
membres qui serait difficilement
mobilisables sur la durée a déclaré le
syndicat la cfe cgc qui avec amené en
moins toujours le retrait du projet de
réforme des retraites comme l'ensemble
de l'intersyndicale est comme l'ensemble
des personnes présentes ici on acquiert
une qualification à la fin de sa
carrière
on doit la garder avec sa retraite pour
garder le même niveau de vie et ce chez
les profs dans les transports partout on
s'en fiche donc ça nous touche plus nous
que d'autres gens c'est ça qu'ils n'ont
pas compris blanc caire et les autres
c'est que ils nous offrent des
revalorisations par prime avec des
contreparties
on va devoir bosser pendant les vacances
on va devoir accepter des missions
supplémentaires et ces noms viennent on
ne veut pas de cette transformation du
métier vous n'aurez pas moi je pense
qu'il faut continuer le combat
aujourd'hui est de s'inscrire dans un
combat de contre-pouvoir pendant deux
ans on adapte un petit peu les préceptes
qu'ont pu utiliser les gilet jaune
depuis un an et de sortir de ce schéma
institutionnel qui est celui de la grève
manifestations piquets de grève et
assemblées générales et ben là
aujourd'hui les syndiqués vont là où
l'état ne les attend pas la plupart des
personnes interrogées au cours de cette
marche aux flambeaux ont déclaré vouloir
participer à cette importante journée de
mobilisation ce vendredi alors que le
projet de réforme des retraites doit
être présenté en conseil des ministres
est le projet de réforme est donc comme
l'a dit notre reporter présenté en
conseil des ministres demain avant
d'arriver au parlement début février une
étape clé pour une réforme contestée
depuis maintenant cinquante jours sur le
fort sur la forme mais sur le fond
évidemment aussi le projet divise
notamment les syndicats si l'âge pivot
été retiré provisoirement les dés sont
ils jetés la réforme suivra-t-elle sont
pour quoi qu'il arrive c'est l'objet de
notre face à face ce soir
[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes avec
pierre roger secrétaire national cfc gc
sur ce plateau bonsoir et merci d'être
avec nous à marseille en direct
alain trannoy professeur à l'école
d'économie d'aix-marseille bonsoir
monsieur trannoy merci avec nous en
direct sur un défense également depuis
marseille donc une question tout d'abord
à notre invité sur ce plateau de la cfe
cgc on l'a dit qui demandent une pause 1
après la mobilisation de vendredi une
pause dans quoi dans la mobilisation
tout en demandant toujours le retrait du
projet pour quelles raisons cette
requête de pause pour la cfe cgc
la priorité ça toujours été de dialoguer
chaque fois et dans les semaines qui ont
précédé cette mobilisation
chaque fois que il ya eu des phases
d'ouverture on a on a fait une pause et
on a essayé de discuter malheureusement
jusqu'à présent
la discussion était relativement stérile
alors la conférence de financement va
s'ouvrir le 30 janvier pour nous il est
naturel en tant que partenaire social de
2 10 rebonds on va participer
franchement est complètement à cette
phase on verra quel est le résultat à
côté de ça vous imaginez bien que nous
allons nous avons déjà entamé un salon
de discussion maintenant avec les
parlementaires
et puis surtout pour répondre à votre
question et le débat commence nous
attendons les mesures d'impact nous
attendons de recevoir le dossier qui
comporte pratiquement 1000 pages on va
confronter nos chiffres avec ceux
annoncés par le gouvernement
et là je pense qu'on va pouvoir rentrer
dans une vraie phase d'information et
d'explication auprès des français au
sens large qui aujourd'hui il faut bien
le reconnaître ont beaucoup de
difficultés mais si vous regardez la
presse et notamment cette presse très
récente depuis quelques jours ont
beaucoup d'informations commence à se
diffuser
on voit qu'en retour les français
commencent à prendre l'ampleur le sujet
qui est un sujet très compliqué alain
trannoy recettes stratégie effectivement
du syndicat réformiste cfe cgc marque un
temps de pause peut-être dans la
mobilisation pour qu'enfin les débats il
est temps j'ai envie de vous dire
puisque ça fait plusieurs mois voire
plusieurs années que c'était supposé
commencer pour qu'enfin les débats
commencent vous avez aussi le sentiment
vous qu'on commence à apprendre vous
véritablement des choses concrètes sur
ce projet de réforme
effectivement parce que c'est une
réforme systémique
une réforme qui touche je dirais tous
les compartiments de la retraite
partout où toutes les catégories de
retraités possible ça touche également
les gens qui vont contribuer et ceci
pour il est toutes les décennies à venir
or en face de ce projet systémique comme
vient de le dire monsieur roger ce n'est
que ce soir
que le gouvernement sort un document de
1000 pages concernant les études
d'impact c'est à dire bon probablement
quelques années le coût financier de la
réforme
est ce que la réforme va être équilibré
financièrement
quels sont tous les quatre types je
crois qu'il ya à peu près plus de 135
cas types qui sont étudiées pour savoir
est ce que les gens vont gagner ou est
ce que les gens vont perdre à la réforme
donc c'est une réforme extrêmement
complexe c'est une réforme systémique et
pour l'instant il faut bien dire que le
gouvernement était assez avare
d'informations
ah non oui on prend à eux il y ait une
angoisse dans le pays
évidemment il ya des gens qui protestent
mais il ya tous les gens qui sont dans
leur salon et qui se disent à quelle
sauce on va être mangé donc je dirais
que effectivement le débat ne commence
que maintenant et on peut se dire que
quelque part
ben sur les deux ans sur lequel a couru
la négociation n'ont pas la négociation
mais la discussion avec entre le
gouvernement les syndicats il ya eu je
dirais des moments qui n'ont pas été
mises à profit pour essayer de faire
avancer les connaissances l'information
sur la réforme de leur gouvernement
avait en tête
il faut bien comprendre qu'en fait va
apparaître petit à petit un élément qui
est passée totalement sous silence pour
la grande majorité de la population
c'est que le grand gagnant de cette
affaire on s'est principalement l'état
en tant qu'employeur d'état en tant
qu'employeur dans cette opération
pour quelles raisons va est bien écouter
parce qu'aujourd'hui l'état en tant
qu'employeur de la fonction publique est
un employeur qui payent beaucoup plus de
cotisations qu'un employeur dans le
secteur privé
suivant les secteurs ça varie entre 75
et 30% en moyenne
demain on a un système qui va qui va
faire que la fonction publique au sens
large va avoir un même taux de
cotisation alors ça va se faire
progressivement avec le secteur privé
donc on peut penser a priori comme ça
que l'on se dise on va vers une forme
d'égalité et c'est ce que les français
ont conclu au départ ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que le grand gagnant
dans l' affaire c'est que certes les
hampes les cotisations vont augmenter un
petit peu du côté et des salariés afin
dé du secteur public
j'en parle des fonctionnaires mais
l'état lui va voir son taux de
cotisation pc 2 en moyenne de 30% ce qui
représente en bien peu près d'ailleurs
ça commence à sortir les chiffres sont
sortis à travers les premiers éléments
c'est ce qu'on avait estimé ses 45
milliards d'économies en gros donc
d'accord entre servira dé revenir
pendant longtemps soit déçu parce que
les revalorisations qui sont prévues sur
le long terme ne concerne que les les
fonctionnaires qui sont les dents les
plus basses catégories et ceux qui ont
peu de prise
les professeurs il ya une partie qui va
être bien sûr distribués mais le grand
gagnant la danse et le budget de l'état
qui lui va voir sa contribution baissé
mais le nombre de
retraités globalement lui va rester en
fixant un équilibre avec un budget à 13
14%
les français vont vite comprendre que
sur le long terme
la pension en moyenne des français en
terre de remplacement va diminuer et on
voit bien et c'est l'autre sujet quand
on parle du passage des 8 à 3 plafonds
que on va aussi vers un système qui
demain la répartition en france sera
beaucoup moins généreuse qu'elle ne l'a
été dans le passé
on va donc tout faire un changement de
système certains d'ailleurs l'on dit à
travers les interviews vous avez le
présentée tout à l'heure chacun exprime
à sa façon mais inévitablement à travers
les chiffres contre ceux ci vont sortir
et commence à sortir il va y avoir cette
découverte par les français le bas le
système qu'on leur présente c'est pas
exactement le système par points
universelles telles que il avait été
peut-être présenter au départ est en
tout cas que certains imaginaient les
économistes qui sont à l'origine de ce
système là aujourd'hui ne se
reconnaissent pas dans ce que présente
le gouvernement et des interventions qui
ont été faites de personnes qu'il se
cache pas d'être à l'origine de ces
propositions
on voit bien que bercy a pris cette
opération par opportuniste et d'ailleurs
les difficultés qu'à eues monsieur de le
voir à exprimer ce qu'il voulait faire
au départ il a été complètement barré
par bercy qui chaque fois il annonçait
quelque chose on va dire d'équilibré ou
de chez vers eux le chiffrage qui était
proposée sec
il a été obligé de rester un peu quoi
etc on aboutit à une discussion à une
absence de discussions pendant deux ans
monsieur delevoye a même dit lui-même sa
sa démission plusieurs fois dans la
balance
je vous rappelle qu'à l'origine on
devrait avoir un système qui devait
pousser les français à travailler plus
longtemps en leur proposant une surcote
pour les inciter à travailler ce qui est
quelque chose que l'on peut comprendre
compte tenu de la démographie autres on
les passait un système de décote
on a parlé de l'ach pivot l'instaurer un
durée de cotisation de 43 ans qui dans
un système par points par nature n'a pas
de sens et donc le système a été
complètement dévié on arrive aujourd'hui
espèce de solution un peu compliqué avec
une conférence de financement dont on ne
voit pas trop bien comment ça va vite
c'est la conférence de financement
pierre roger dans quelques instants d'un
trannoy sur l'analyse en tout cas la
première partie de pierre roger ça sera
forcément un système moins généreux pour
les français selon
ce que vous avez pu lire ici ou là
l'économiste que vous êtes en pense quoi
alors il ya un point sur lequel je suis
entièrement d'accord avec monsieur roger
c'est le fait que on a vendu cette
réforme est d'ailleurs c'était dans le
programme d' emmanuel macron il était
candidat à la présidence de la
république
on a vendu cette réforme sous le couvert
d d'essayer d'établir une égalité alors
le mot égalité c'est pas exactement
l'équité donc en tout cas c'était plus
d'égalité dans le calcul de la pension
de retraite et à l'arrivée on se rend
compte et là il ya un certain nombre
d'études qui sortent en ce moment et qui
montre bien que cet objectif il sera
plus ou moins en fonction des
différentes concessions qui ont été
accordés un certain nombre de deux
régimes spéciaux sera cet objectif de
qualité sera plus ou moins vérifiées il
sera peut-être un peu écornée mais c'est
surtout que est venue se rajouter un
autre objectif aider le gouvernement à
avancer masqué ainsi que le président de
la république on peut le dire puisque
c'était pas dans son programme
c'est en fait un allongement de la durée
du travail
je vous rappelle quand 80 françois
mitterrand a baissé la non la raab a
abaissé l'âge de on pouvait partir en
retraite de 65 ans à 60 ans avec la
réforme sarkozy on était à 62 ans pour
l'âge légal on discute plus de l'âge
légal mais on discute maintenant de
l'âge à partir duquel il ya plus de
décote
et quand on regarde je dirais les
différents cas types qui sont présentés
lorsqu'on les compare avec les retraites
qui auraient été assurés dans le système
actuel
eh bien on se rend compte que grosso
modo pratiquement il ya il va y avoir un
recul de 3 ans de l'âge à partir duquel
on
on va pas reprendre à retraite sans
décote donc c'est je dirais la
superposition de ces deux objectifs qui
rend évidemment les français méfiant par
rapport à ce projet parce que en tant
qu'économiste bien évidemment on peut
dire que cet allongement de la durée du
travail est assez naturel vu les progrès
dans l'espérance de vie
oui mais c'était je dirais essai il ya
un certain nombre on sait que la société
française
l'économie française a un certain nombre
de problèmes avec une dette élevée et
globalement on peut dire qu'il ya pas
assez de travail
ya pas assez de richesses qui sont
produits donc évidemment l'allongement
de la durée du travail si on arrive à
anne pas garder des gens au chômage et à
les faire travailler
je parle évidemment pour des gens qui
sont pas sur des métiers pénibles qu'ils
sont en bonne santé etc
c'est effectivement un projet pour
mettre de la richesse créer plus de
richesses et donc pour conserver un
relativement haut niveau de pension la
france a relativement à d'autres pays
européens sur la répartition au niveau
de pension donc en fait c'est ça la
solution s'est proposé comme peine à
rouen la petite divergence
d'appréciation
jeu sur la première partie je peux je
peux comprendre ce que ce que vous dites
en revanche nom et
il y aura pas au niveau de pension il ya
surtout dans ce système là le fait que
l'état et il est assez clairement
indiqué dans le rapport du cor que vous
avez sans doute pu lire ou mois de
novembre c'est clairement indiquée pour
la première partie jusqu'en 2027
les fameux 12 milliards que la
conférence va chercher à trouver en
dehors d'un la solution inévitable
ah bon la vie d'un report de l'âge des
équilibres qui arrivera de toute façon
sous cette forme-là ou sous une autre
appellation de manière inévitable
c'est parce que il ya une baisse non pas
un problème de deux pensions à verser
mais une baisse des recettes qui
viennent principalement du fait que
l'état n'assume pas son rôle tel qu'il
existait aujourd'hui l'exemple numéro un
qui est typique c'est la sphère des
gilets jaunes la non compensation des
cotisations sur les heures
supplémentaires
c'est un milliard en milliards de en
moyenne par an entre demain et 2027 qui
peu ou prou fait quasiment les trois
quarts du déficit des 12 milliards
quand l'état dit je vais réduire le
nombre de fonctionnaires donc je ne
l'aurais pas à payer les cotisations
afférentes c'est un choix politique
c'est bien et le corps l'a très bien
exprimé il n'y a pas de problème de
financement des retraites il ya un
problème de simplement de réduction des
recettes et lorsqu'on réduit entre temps
les pensions de 8 à 3 plafonds chez les
cadres que nous ne réclamons pas ces
essais clairement dans les notes de
l'agirc arrco qui sont parus début
janvier et qui sont commencé à se
répandre dans toute la presse et qui est
donc de journaux en ont fait les échos
c'est le cas de le dire
ces 4 5 milliards en moyenne par an en
moins de recettes
la volonté c'est clairement de faire
baisser le poids des retraites sur le
pib en france parce qu'il ya
effectivement d'autres choix de dépenses
qu'on souhaite mettre en oeuvre mais
c'est certainement pas pour améliorer le
niveau moyen des pensions sur le long
terme il y aura six millions de français
qui vont passer plus 65 ans dans les
années qui viennent
à partir du moment où on maintient et
s'est clairement exprimé d'ailleurs dans
le rapport c'est encore été dit la
volonté de descendre la part de des
retraites à 11 tous % en moyenne sur la
durée mathématiquement le taux de
pension et la pension moyenne sera à la
baisse et c'est pour ça qu'elle à côté
on a mis la loi pâques pour inciter
effectivement à renforcer tous les
moyens de capitalisation ce qui pose un
autre problème par rapport effectivement
au choix français qui est depuis 45 de
la répartition et je comprends que pour
certains ce soit troublant surtout pour
ceux qui n'auront pas les moyens de
mettre de l'argent de côté et
malheureusement ils sont assez nombreux
donc là encore en termes d'égalité on
peut s'interroger si vraiment ce choix
il est vraiment judicieux l1 trannoy
rapidement la conclusion puisque vous
répondez pierre roger sur ce plateau
conclusions de ce débat alors sur le
dernier point concernant le fait qu'il y
aura effectivement plusieurs milliards
de d'euros de recettes en moins du fait
qu' on abaisse le plafond de sécurité
sociale enfin le délai actuellement les
cadres cotisent et jusqu'à 8 huit fois
le plafond oui une fois le plafond des
tirs et socialement ils vont plus
cotiser pour leur retraite que qu'à
trois fois le plafond
il ya effectivement moins de recettes il
ya aussi moins de retraite contributives
au titre du système de la répartition
qui sont versées à des cadres c'est un
choix fondamental est clairement ça n'a
pas été discuté suffisamment avec
monsieur roger représente un syndicat
qui il ya beaucoup d'adhérents de cadres
et donc ça n'a pas été discuté
suffisamment dans la société française
c'est un choix effectivement important
car ça favorise forcément pour en tout
cas les cadres à hauts salaires très
élevés ould abdi 1000 euros la retraite
par capitalisation
on peut se demander si c'est pas un
projet je dirais plus globale d'essayer
de favoriser la retraite par
capitalisation
alors ceci dit
c'est un choix de société qui n'a pas
été clairement exprimée aux français et
pour lequel les chaussures à mon avis
donc la vérité je suis d'accord que
c'est un choix de société qui n'a pas
été clairement exprimées et des français
ceci dit si on est d'accord avec
l'analyse de thomas piketty que le taux
de rendement au 21e siècle sera plus
élevé que le taux de croissance il faut
quand même faire attention à ne pas
forcément je dirais diaboliser la cape
la capitalisation en particulier au
niveau collectif personnellement je suis
pour que la france constitue un fonds
souverain comme le fait un grand pays
démocratique qui est qui et la norvège
parce que au cours du 21e siècle il peut
y avoir bien évidemment des crises
financières il peut y avoir bien
évidemment des crises économiques
il peut y avoir l'intelligence
artificielle qui réduit le poids des
salaires dans l'économie mais
fondamentalement le problème numéro un
que nous avons tous c de réchauffement
climatique et ce réchauffement
climatique peut avoir des comptes et des
conséquences inquiétantes sur je dirais
notre niveau de vie très très très
concrètement et donc il faut je dirais
faire en sorte que la france puisse
puiser dans un trésor accumulé dans des
dents cas dans des temps calmes ce cas
ce qu'a fait la norvège et y compris
pour payer les pensions qu'ils ne
pourraient plus est payé par le système
de répartition
donc je pense que la capitalisation ça
peut être une capitulation à titre
individuel sap est un titre disons de
l'ensemble des salariés est une
entreprise peut peut cotiser également
mais ça peut être aussi au niveau d'un
état au niveau de toute la nation
et je rappelle qu'en 45 il ya une
hésitation entre le choix de la
capitalisation et le choix de la
répartition a aujourd'hui on nous
propose c'est sûr tout utiliser le fonds
de réserve des retraites pour combler
les trous à court terme
donc je pense pas qu'on aille vers ce
que vous proposez et c'est bien les
agréments du débat c'est une grave
erreur mais je pense que là c'est une
erreur profonde d'utiliser les réserves
actuelles au lieu
d'accumuler et d'essayer que ses
réserves face des petits ou cas où il y
aurait des grosses difficultés et je
pense qu' il peut y avoir des grosses
difficultés au 21e siècle on aime on
terminera sur cet accord merci en tout
cas à vous on a appris plein de choses
pierre roger alain trannoy merci ça
d'avoir été avec nous à la veille donc
de cette grande journée de mobilisation
alors que votre syndicat demande une
pause après cette journée de
mobilisation dans la grève mais
demandent toujours le retrait bien
évidemment du l'objet de réformes merci
à vous deux est en pleine contestation
sociale contre cette réforme blackrock
annonce investi hier pour
l'environnement lors de sa 50e édition
du forum de davos le plus grand
gestionnaire d'actifs du monde à
présenter un fonds d'investissement vert
en partenariat avec la france et
l'allemagne
alors de quoi s'agit-il éléments de
réponse avec nadège abderrazak en france
blackrock jouit d'une mauvaise
réputation le plus grand gestionnaire
d'actifs du monde a en effet été dépeint
comme l'inspirateur cachée du projet de
réforme sur les retraites ce géant
américain gère l'équivalent de 7000
milliards de dollars dans le monde et il
vient d'annoncer investir 500 millions
de dollars pour lutter contre le
changement climatique
autant dire une goutte d'eau un
partenariat qui doit mais les capitaux
philanthropique publics et privés vers
eric rugby il m'est apparu très
clairement que de plus en plus de
clients réfléchissent à la manière dont
ils devraient investir m'est apparu très
clairement que toute la question du
changement climatique est vraiment lié
aux certitudes ou aux incertitudes
scientifiques ne suis pas un
scientifique mais de plus en plus de
gens croient en une forme de sciences et
pas en d'autres savent et en étant sur
le marché des capitaux depuis maintenant
quarante quatre ans il est très clair
que noire sur les marchés des capitaux
nous allons au devant du risque et nous
n'attendons pas que le risque soit
devant nous
ce partenariat c'est le nom de ce
nouveau fonds d'investissement plusieurs
fondations la france et l'allemagne ont
annoncé participer à l'initiative
paris et berlin doivent chacun investir
à hauteur de 30 millions de dollars
les défis liés aux changements
climatiques exige de mener des actions
collectives d'envergure ce partenariat
ambitieux contribuera à réorienter les
flux de capitaux vers des
investissements de développement durable
dans les pays émergents et ciblera en
priorité l'afrique
le fonds investira dans des
infrastructures durables comme les
énergies renouvelables l'efficacité
énergétique le stockage d'énergie etc
il ciblera les pays d'asie du sud-est
d'amérique latine et pour au moins 25 %
des investissements les pays d'afrique
blackrock souhaite faire passer ces
investissements durables de 90 milliards
à 1000 milliards d'ici dix ans il compte
aussi se débarrasser des titres publics
deux sociétés qui génèrent plus de 25 %
de leurs revenus à partir de la
production de charbon thermique passer
des paroles aux actes c'est ce
qu'attendent plusieurs ong
mais pour l'heure greenpeace se montrent
sceptiques
les sociétés financières sont
aujourd'hui tout autant responsables que
les industriels des énergies fossiles
blackrock a annoncé qu'il allait réduire
leurs financements du charbon mais ils
n'ont pas dit quand ils n'ont pas inclus
d'autres énergies fossiles de toutes les
énergies fossiles le charbon est la plus
néfaste pour la planète pour espérer
limiter le réchauffement à plus d'1 5
degrés par rapport à l'ère
préindustrielle il faudrait réduire
l'utilisation du charbon de deux tiers
d'ici 2030 est quasiment à zéro en 2050
et c'est plus facile à dire qu'à faire
le greenwashing a donc encore de beaux
jours devant lui
restait la fin de cette édition tu
retrouves dans trois minutes deux
minutes ou même pour un point complet
sur l'actualité
[Musique]
comment pas te le donne en mille autres
pas seulement le cinéma
ils sont le cinéma
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
charles pathé a le génie des affaires
léon gaumont est un ingénieur surdoué
ces deux hommes que tout oppose et se
sont forgé une destinée commune dans une
perpétuelle surenchère ils ont bâti
chacun leur empire et dominer le monde
[Musique]
et
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord ici qu'on invite les plus
compétents pas seulement ceux qui
parlent le plus fort ici on reçoit c'est
qu'on ne voit pas ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici c'est interdit d'interdire
ces sentiments que vous avez eue vous
aussi ce besoin d'autonomie
oui complètement besoin d'autonomie
besoin de retourner à des choses plus
essentielles en fait est vraiment de
sentir qu'on n'est pas forcément un
poids pour la planète
il ya une idée derrière il ya une
philosophie aussi qu'on a vu la serre
les plantes poussent le fait de vivre
avec les plantes comme ça vraiment
commune comme une machine un organisme
pour faire partie de cet organisme
on a eu vraiment l'impression de se
construire en même temps quand vous
construisez cette maison en faisant
toutes ces rencontres et je pense que
ces genres de projets qui se fait pas
tout seul dans son coin on est dans un
truc vraiment de coopération de partage
de partage
[Musique]
le 5e forum international sur la shoah
s'est tenue aujourd'hui à jérusalem
nombreux dirigeants présents dont
vladimir poutine emmanuel macron ou
encore mike pence
une journée vont se souvenir également
des soldats de l'armée rouge libérateur
du camp d'auschwitz ce matin le
président russe a assisté à
l'inauguration d'un monument consacré à
ceux qui ont subi le siège de leningrad
aux états unis de procès en destitution
de donald trump au centre des attentions
après les
débat technique démocrates et
républicains sont entrés dans le vif du
sujet hier pour la troisième fois de son
histoire un président américain est
confronté un procès en destitution
donald trump est accusé d'abus de
pouvoir d'obstruction au congrès le
projet de réforme des retraites est
présenté en conseil des ministres demain
avant d'arriver au parlement début
février une étape clé pour une réforme
contestée depuis 50 jours
sur la forme sur le fond le projet du
vinyle notamment les syndicats si l'âge
pivot été retiré provisoirement les dés
sont ils jetés la réponse suivra-t-elle
son cours quoi qu'il arrive une grande
mobilisation a lieu encore demain
[Musique]
merci nous rejoindre en direct sur rt
france journée mémorielle donc
aujourd'hui notamment pour se souvenir
de la libération du camp d'auschwitz
était le 27 janvier il y à 75 ans des
dirigeants du monde ont qui est sont à
jérusalem pour participer au forum
mondial de la shoah il serait dont l'on
retrouve notre envoyé spécial tome
abonnés pendant plus de trois heures les
discours se sont succédé des discours
parfois plein d'émotions toujours très
grave qui rendent souvent hommage aux
victimes de la shoah et également aux
survivants de l'holocauste qui pour
certains d'entre eux sont présents au
mémorial de yad vashem c'est le
président israélien rivlin qui a appris
la parole en premier avec ces mots très
forts les portes de l'enfer se sont
ouvertes le 27 janvier 1945 le 27
janvier 1945 c'est la date à laquelle
l'armée rouge a libéré le camp
d'auschwitz on retiendra également les
propos de vladimir poutine qui a
expliqué que l'union soviétique a payé
un lourd tribut avec environ 27 millions
de morts pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale beaucoup de juifs étaient
originaires d'union soviétique a déclaré
vladimir poutine qui a également pointé
la collaboration de certains pays avec
l'allemagne nazie il faut défendre la
vérité et la justice a par ailleurs
déclaré le président russe vladimir
poutine qui a également soumis une idée
celle de la tenue d'une réunion du
conseil de sécurité des nations unies en
2020 est ce la lumière de la coopération
efficace des pays alliés en 1945
une réunion du conseil de sécurité des
nations unies cette année une idée
approuvée par emmanuel macron les
écoutes les cinq grandes puissances
fondatrice de
l'onu sont garantes du maintien de la
civilisation nous en avait parlé avec
mes homologues et nous sommes tout à
fait d'accord sur deux d'organiser une
réunion d de ces pays c'est à dire etats
unis russie chine france et grande
bretagne pour que nous puissions parler
de cela n'importe où n'importe où et la
russie tout à fait prête à accueillir un
tel forum intel d'une telle discussion
et je vous rejoins cher vladimir
monsieur le président poutine les cinq
membres permanents du conseil de
sécurité des nations unies ont
aujourd'hui une responsabilité
historique
je partage votre volonté 75 ans plus
tard de nous rassembler tous ensemble
nous l'avons évoqué il ya quelques jours
et je souhaite que nous puissions le
faire car nous sommes de par cette
histoire est depuis la fin du deuxième
conflit mondial les garants d'un ordre
international qui tient par le droit la
légalité et le respect de chacun au delà
des hommages les discours étaient
parfois très politique ce fut notamment
le cas lorsque benyamin netanyahou le
premier ministre israélien a pris la
parole au pupitre il a d'abord insisté
sur l'importance de l'armée israélienne
et de ce qu'il qualifie de boucliers un
bouclier contre les menaces et il a
nommé très directement une de ces
menaces
selon lui il s'agit de l'iran un
discours repris par les etats-unis
représentés cet après midi par le
vice-président américain mike pence on
écoute nous devons encore attendre une
action résolue g contre le régime le
plus antisémite qui existent sur la
planète
un régime qui cherche ouvertement à
développer des armes nucléaires pour
anéantir l'unique le seul état juif du
clan ces tyrans de téhéran qui ont
persécuté leur propre peuple qui met en
cause la sécurité de toute la région de
tous les pays du proche orient et même
du monde entier j'appelle tous les
gouvernements à rejoindre cet effort est
essentielle et à faire face à suivre il
ne s'inspire dans ce même esprit oui
mother toutefois aussi rester forts
gains contre cet état prévalant
d'antisémitisme contre un gouvernement
monde qui adopte une petite étape nier
la shoah et qu'ils voudraient c'est
israël de la carte mondiale est bien le
fils d'israël doit rester fermes contre
la république terran islamique d'iran
une cérémonie qui s'est terminée par des
hommages successifs des différentes
délégations internationales présentes
elles sont au nombre de 49 49
personnalités politiques des 49 pays qui
ont fait le déplacement ici à jérusalem
pour ce qui est qualifié de plus grand
événement diplomatique de l'histoire du
pays tri pour jean de gliniasty
chercheur à l'iris ancien ambassadeur de
france à moscou certains cherchent
peut-être à tirer profit de cette
cérémonie les 75 ans de schmitz
évidemment
on y retrouve à ce moment là la
convergence à la fois d'un propres enfin
d'une préoccupation global lutter contre
l'antisémitisme
et puis aussi il faut le dire disons les
préoccupations plus nationale d'un
certain nombre de dirigeants
on sait que natanyahou est en pleines
difficultés pour constituer un
gouvernement il va probablement
affronter de nouvelles élections donc on
sait en france aussi la résurgence de
l'antisémitisme est un problème
politique
on sait que par exemple effectivement le
président américain est en pleine
procédure d' impeachment est en fait
commémorer la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme
la lutte contre le nazisme la libération
des camps de concentration
c'est pas forcément mauvais sur le plan
électoral sur le plan de politique
intérieure pour chacun de ses dirigeants
non il y aura toujours une tentation
fondée ou infondée d'un certain nombre
de dirigeants que ce soit les américains
les russes les polonais des états
d'utiliser l'histoire leurs profits ça
c'est clair
et en marge de ces hommages lundi maire
poutine a rencontré le président de
l'autorité palestinienne mahmoud abbas
les deux dirigeants ont fait part de
leur volonté de renforcer leur
coopération
ces visites que ce soit en palestine ou
à moscou sont importantes pour nous afin
de nous consulter sur toutes les
questions qui nous concernent
à cette occasion je remercie monsieur le
président d'avoir soutenu le peuple
palestinien sur les plans politique
économique culturel financier et
sécuritaire
nous avons des problématiques
importantes dans la région dont nous
devons discuter avec le président russe
qu'elles soient liées à l'annoncé par
israël de l'annexion des territoires
palestiniens et nous discuterons
également de l'accord du siècle annoncé
par trump nous nous réunissons
régulièrement et avons des contacts
réguliers les relations russo
palestiniennes ont de longue tradition
nous entretenons des relations dans
différents secteurs
vous venez d mentionné nous sommes prêts
à renforcer cette coopération
concerne les relations économiques et
humanitaires et le règlement du conflit
israëlo palestinien dont comprenons vos
préoccupations concernant cette
situation je suis heureux d'avoir des
consultations sur ces questions et sur
une situation régionale dans un contexte
de plus la bienvenue à la demande de la
russie à cette tenue à l'onu à new york
le 20 janvier l'objectif était de
discuter de l'intégrité de l'équipe de
l'eau eyath ayant enquêté sur la taxe
chimiques présumées de douma en avril
contesté par les représentants russes un
ancien expert de l'aeia c'est déjà cité
par wikileaks est intervenu pour réfuter
la version finale de l' enquête
les explications de katia pique nique
nouveau rebondissement dans le dossier
sur la taxe chimiques présumées de douma
en syrie en 2018
le 20 janvier dernier une réunion du
conseil de sécurité en formule arria a
été demandée par moscou lors de cet
échange informel vassili n'est benzia
représentant permanent de la russie a
souhaité remettre en question le rapport
de l'organisation pour l'interdiction
des armes chimiques sur la taca douma le
7 avril 2018 un bombardement attribué
par l'occident aux troupes de bachar
al-assad avait entraîné la mort de
quelques dizaines de personnes des pays
occidentaux avaient soupçonné une
utilisation d'agents chimiques
l'incident avaient entraîné des frappes
le 13 avril de la part des etats-unis de
la france et du royaume uni sur le
centre de recherche de basée en syrie
les experts de louis ac avaient mené
leur enquête puis publié un court
document préliminaire en juillet 2018
les enquêteurs n'avaient pas trouvé de
traces de gaz sarin mais de produits
chimiques chlorés
après des investigations complémentaires
le rapport final en mars 2019 a statué
ce produit chimique contenait un réactif
du chlore le produit toxique était
vraisemblablement dû clore moléculaire
mais des documents révélés par wikileaks
depuis octobre 2019 ont dévoilé qu'un
ancien expert de l'aeia c'est ian
henderson avait exprimé des doutes sur
une des analyses du rapport concernant
des cylindres après avoir collecté des
informations sur les lieux du
bombardement
mais il ne faisait pas partie des
experts retenus pour la mission la ffm
laquelle ne lui as
jamais demandé d' expertise jan
andersson ensuite expliqué à des membres
de l'onu que le rapport final constitue
un revirement par rapport aux
observations de l'équipe sur place
les conclusions du rapport final de la
ffm étaient contradictoires était un
revirement complet de ce que l'équipe
avait collectivement déduit pendant et
suivant les enquêtes à la douma et au
moment de la publication du rapport
intermédiaire notre avis était que nous
avions de sérieux doutes sur le fait
qu'une attaque chimique est eu lieu si
l'on excepte henderson aucun membre de
l'équipe de terrain a contredit
jusqu'ici le rapport mais ian henderson
reproche à la ffm de n'avoir pas tenu
compte des remarques contradictoires de
son rapport balistique qui l'a envoyé à
l'équipe la veille de la publication du
document final le rapport n'a pas fait
toute la lumière sur les nouvelles
découvertes informations données ou
analyses dans le domaine des témoignages
des études toxicologiques des analyses
chimiques des études d'ingénierie et de
balistique et en définitive a produit un
revirement complet par rapport à ce que
la majorité de l'équipe et l'équipe
entière de la douma pensait en juillet
en ce qui me concerne j'ai poursuivi
pendant six mois une étude balistique et
d'ingénierie sur les cylindres qui m'ont
conduit à donner davantage de crédit au
fait qu'il n'y ait pas eu à thaksin
le rapport de l'oif s'est fait toutefois
mention d' analyses balistiques
indépendante de trois pays affirmant que
les cylindres sont bien tombés du ciel
plusieurs membres du conseil de sécurité
ont débattu du témoignage de jan
andersson chacun restant sur ses
positions nous devons défendre la
crédibilité et les conclusions de l'oéa
c'est ainsi que les nations unies contre
la désinformation chamoux incluse
led by the united states of america
certains pays guidé par les états unis
continuent d'outrepasser les
dispositions de la convention sur
l'interdiction des armes chimiques en
politisant le travail de lobby assez et
en s'écartant de la voix pour laquelle
elle a été créée dirrell franck de
traque et wasquehal y étaient de faux
alexander shulgin représentant de la
russie auprès de l'organisation pour
l'interdiction des armes chimiques
interroge la crédibilité de l'organisme
et a suggéré une solution
nous proposons une fois de plus de
résoudre ce différend en organisant une
rencontre avec le jass et avec l'aide
possible d état membre requérant la
participation de tous les membres de la
ffm qui ont travaillé sur le rapport de
la doue main afin de parvenir enfin à un
consensus sur le sujet de l'incident
survenu dans la ville syrienne l'oeil ac
qui a décliné l'invitation à cette
réunion a publiquement peu défendu les
conclusions du rapport dont elle dit
qu'il se base sur des analyses
scientifiques concordantes
et alors que les spéculations émergent
seuls les représentants de cet organisme
pourrait enfin mettre fin à la
controverse en acceptant de s'exprimer
aux etats unis la parole est toujours à
l'accusation dans le procès en
destitution de donald trump après une
première journée très technique les 100
sénateurs ont abordé hier le fond du
dossier
pendant près de neuf heures l'élu
démocrate de la chambre des
représentants adam schiff assisté par
six confrères est revenu sur les deux
chefs d'accusation retenus contre le
locataire de la maison blanche et abus
de pouvoir et entrave du travail du
congrès pour en parler nous sommes avec
notre envoyé spécial de radel razika
washington doha bonsoir les démocrates
qui dispose de quelques jours seulement
pour tenter de convaincre les sénateurs
de la culpabilité de donald trump
troisième jour de ce procès historique
les démocrates redoublent d'efforts ils
poursuivent en ce moment même leur
argument pour destituer pour démettre
donald trump de ses fonctions lors pour
eux aucun doute donald trump est
coupable d'abus de pouvoir et dont trava
là
marches du congrès et accuse le
président américain d'avoir fait
pression sur l'ukraine pour qu'elle
enquête sur son potentiel rival à la
présidentielle de novembre
le démocrate joe biden on le voit bien
les démocrates sont bloqués puisque le
sénat ne leur a pas permis la
convocation de témoins lors de ce procès
alors ils utilisent plutôt leur temps
pour décrire un long récit appuyé
d'extraits vidéo vidéo de déclarations
de donald trump mais également des
témoignages qui ont été présentées lors
des audiences à la chambre des
représentants ils vont poursuivre leurs
plaidoiries tout au long de la journée
ainsi que demain je vous rappelle qu'il
dispose de 24 heures sur trois jours ce
qui signifie que dès samedi l'équipe de
défense de donald trump entrera en scène
il dispose également du même temps de
parole alors un procès qui se soldera
sûrement par l'acquittement du président
américain puisque le sénat est
majoritairement républicain mais les
démocrates cherchent surtout et bien à
convaincre les électeurs qui se trouve
derrière leur poste de ne pas réélire
donald trump en novembre le procès en
destitution du président américain est
retransmis en direct à la télévision
il a déjà et bien réunis est plutôt
attiré 11 millions de téléspectateurs
ici aux etats unis
et comme d'habitude le principal
intéressé s'est exprimé et la réagi par
twitter sur twitter pardon à peine
rentré de davos où il assisté au forum
économique mondial
donald trump s'en est violemment pris au
procureur au procureur démocrates ils
les accusent de présenter de manière
mensongère mais aussi injuste et les
faits qui lui sont reprochés
merci adorent abdelrazik en direct de
washington en france
en france le projet de loi sur la
réforme des retraites sera présenté
demain en conseil des ministres alors
qu'une marche aux flambeaux a lieu ce
soir à paris elle s'est élancée de la
place de la nation jusqu'à la place de
la république objective s'échauffer
avant la journée de grève de demain
contre la réforme des retraites
des précisions sur place dans le cortège
vient d'arriver ici place de la
république ce sont entre 1000 et 2000
personnes qui ont participé ce soir à
cette marche aux flambeaux qui est parti
donc de la place de la nation en passant
par le cimetière du père lachaise
l'objectif de cette mobilisation était
double prouver que la contestation
contre la réforme des retraites est
toujours bien vivante et dénoncer
symboliquement la mise à mort du système
de retraite actuel telle mise à mort
d'un modèle social de la société
française qui a fait ses preuves depuis
plus de 70 ans
un système basé sur la solidarité qui
est largement finançables aujourd'hui au
vu des profits monstrueux que produisent
ja lire les salariés en france et les
travailleurs françaises et français et
donc effectivement c'est ils veulent
rayer un modèle de société issue du
conseil national de la résistance et qui
a fait ses preuves en france et nous
pousser vers une capitalisation à
l'anglo saxonne qui va pousser des
millions de français dans la pauvreté la
précarité
cette opération a été organisée par
l'intersyndicale au sein de laquelle on
compte par exemple la cgt force ouvrière
ou encore solidaire c'est près d'une
dizaine de syndicats qui ont appelé à
manifester aujourd'hui
mais parmi cette liste que je viens
d'égrainer vous aurez sans doute noté un
grand absent la cfdt la cfdt qui a
choisi il y à peu la voie du compromis
et de la discussion avec l'exécutif la
cfdt on l'a pas vue depuis le mois de
décembre très clairement
contrairement à 95 puisque j'ai l'âge
d'avoir été aussi manifestants et
grévistes en 1995 où une partie la scène
étaient présents là très clairement elle
a été invisible donc on ne l'attend pas
on ne compte pas sur la cfdt
et puis je crois qu'il a été clairement
montré qu'une partie des conseillers de
la cfdt étaient les mêmes que ceux qui
avaient pu conseiller macron donc voilà
c'est le choix de la de ce syndicat qui
est à côté on peut avoir du mal à
comprendre du mouvement qui se dessine
dans ce pays on vient également
d'apprendre que la cfe cgc a annoncé
vouloir faire une pause dans son
mouvement de grève après la mobilisation
de demain en cause ses membres qui
serait difficilement mobilisables sur la
durée a déclaré le syndicat la cfe cgc
qui réclame néanmoins toujours le
retrait du projet de réforme des
retraites comme l'ensemble de
l'intersyndicale est comme l'ensemble
des personnes présentes ici on acquiert
une qualification à la fin de sa
carrière
on doit la garder avec sa retraite pour
garder le même niveau de vie et ce chez
les profs dans les transports partout on
s'en fiche n'est que ça nous touche plus
nous que d'autres gens c'est ça qu'ils
n'ont pas compris blanc caire et les
autres c'est que ils nous offrent des
revalorisations par prime avec des
contreparties on va devoir bosser
pendant les vacances on va devoir
accepter des missions supplémentaires
et c'est non mais non nous on ne veut
pas de cette transformation du métier
vous n'aurez pas moi je pense qu'il faut
continuer le combat aujourd'hui est de
s'inscrire dans un combat de
contre-pouvoir pendant deux ans on
adapte un petit peu les préceptes qu'ont
pu utiliser les gilets jaunes depuis un
an et de sortir de ce schéma
institutionnel qui est celui de la grève
manifestations piquets de grève et
assemblée générale est bien là
aujourd'hui les syndiqués vont là où
l'état ne les attend pas
la plupart des personnes interrogées au
cours de cette marche aux flambeaux ont
déclaré vouloir participer à cette
importante journée de mobilisation ce
vendredi alors que le projet de réforme
des retraites doit être présenté en
conseil des ministres et en pleine
contestation sociale contre cette
réforme
blackrock annonce investir pour
l'environnement elle lors de la 50e
édition du forum de davos le plus grand
gestionnaire d'actifs du monde à
présenter un fonds d'investissement vert
en partenariat avec la france et
l'allemagne
de quoi s'agit-il éléments de réponse
avec nadège abera sac en france
blackrock jouit d'une mauvaise
réputation le plus grand gestionnaire
d'actifs du monde a en effet été dépeint
comme l'inspirateur cachée du projet de
réforme sur les retraites ce géant
américain gère l'équivalent de 7000
milliards de dollars dans le monde et
lui
annoncé investir 500 millions de dollars
pour lutter contre le changement
climatique
autant dire une goutte d'eau un
partenariat qui doit mais les capitaux
philanthropique publics et privés il
m'est apparu très clairement que de plus
en plus de clients réfléchissent à la
manière dont ils devraient investir
il m'est apparu très clairement que
toute la question du changement
climatique est vraiment lié aux
certitudes ou aux incertitudes
scientifiques ne suis pas un
scientifique mais de plus en plus de
gens croient en une forme de sciences et
pas dans d'autres
vous savez en étant sur le marché des
capitaux depuis maintenant quarante
quatre ans il est très clair que nous
sur les marchés des capitaux
nous allons au devant du risque et nous
n'attendons pas que le risque soit
devant nous c'est le nom de ce nouveau
fonds d'investissement plusieurs
fondations la france et l'allemagne ont
annoncé participer à l'initiative
paris et berlin doivent chacun investir
à hauteur de 30 millions de dollars
les défis liés aux changements
climatiques exige de mener des actions
collectives d'envergure ce partenariat
ambitieux contribuera à réorienter les
flux de capitaux vers des
investissements de développement durable
dans les pays émergents et ciblera en
priorité l'afrique
le fonds investira dans des
infrastructures durables comme les
énergies renouvelables l'efficacité
énergétique le stockage d'énergie etc
il ciblera les pays d'asie du sud-est
d'amérique latine et pour au moins 25 %
des investissements les pays d'afrique
blackrock souhaite faire passer ces
investissements durables de 90 milliards
à 1000 milliards d'ici dix ans il compte
aussi se débarrasser des titres publics
deux sociétés qui génèrent plus de 25 %
de leurs revenus à partir de la
production de charbon thermique passer
des paroles aux actes c'est ce
qu'attendent plusieurs ong
mais pour l'heure
greenpeace se montrent sceptiques les
sociétés financières sont aujourd'hui
tout autant responsables que les
industriels des énergies fossiles
blackrock a annoncé qu'ils allaient
réduire leurs financements du charbon
mais ils n'ont pas dit quand ils n'ont
pas inclus d'autres énergies fossiles de
toutes les énergies fossiles le charbon
est la plus néfaste pour la planète pour
espérer limiter le réchauffement à plus
d'1 5 degrés par rapport à l'ère
préindustrielle il faudrait réduire
l'utilisation du charbon de deux tiers
d'ici 2030 est quasiment à zéro en 2050
et c'est plus facile à dire qu'à faire
le greenwashing a donc encore de beaux
jours devant lui
à londres ce nouveau rassemblement en
soutien à julian assange le fondateur de
wikileaks
les manifestants étaient réunis devant
le tribunal de westminster qui doit
juger de l'extradition du journaliste
aux états unis ces soutiens plaide pour
sa libération au plus vite en raison de
son état de santé et dénonce des
manoeuvres américaines qui porte
atteinte selon eux à la liberté de la
presse écoutez nous avons donc affaire à
un cas politique à la persécution
politique d'un journaliste et à une
grave attaque contre la liberté de la
presse dans le monde qui a été le plus
intéressant cette semaine ce n'est pas
ce qui s'est passé devant la cour
aujourd'hui c'est ce qui est ressorti de
la présentation aux preuves aux états
unis au cours des derniers jours ce qui
en est ressorti c'est tout d'abord
qu'ils sont prêts à déployer un argument
du premier amendement qui ne s'applique
pas un journaliste étranger
c'est donc presque comme un acte de
guerre contre la communauté
internationale des journalistes
et la deuxième chose très ressortir et
que s'ils parviennent à faire entrer
julian assange aux états unis il lui a
mis crois ce qu'on appelle des mesures
administratives spéciales ce qui
signifie que pendant ce procès ni lui ni
son équipe juridique pourront parler au
public ou à la presse de ce qui se passe
et c'est la fin de cette édition merci
d'avoir suivi tout de suite retrouvé
l'autre match grégory pigeons qui
s'intéresse ce soir au dopage scandale
sportif ou arme politique
excellente soirée à toussus rt france
[Musique]
dans ce livre on vous découvre
extrêmement proche de votre mariage très
fusionnelle à ce que vous viviez un peu
dans la peur avec tout ce qui est des
menaces oui d intimidation comme brûler
les locaux oui mais un assassinat
vraiment jeune ans je pense que j'y
croyais pas ceux qui ont été assassinés
étaient